[Music]
two
we're here
we're live
it's april 27th the h3 podcast forever
today right off the bat we're gonna talk
to
you know abey's been preparing for this
boxing match
and we have got the legendary abs coach
here to hopefully humiliate ab
but he sounds like a really interesting
guy as well of course wale
uh omotoso aka lucky boy
thanks for being here wow he represent
thank you for inviting me abe wasn't
sure you'd come he thinks you're too
hard you think you're a hard ass you
didn't think you'd want to come
no actually you know just a little bit
push i don't you need a little punch
yeah a little bit pretty yeah yeah not
like i'm
high dude just a little bit yeah okay
amy's scared of you do you think that's
warranted
i think everyone's scared of him is
everyone
you seem like a very nice uh
you seem like a very sweet guy based on
my my
just meeting you yeah so why people
scared you
you know
i don't know is it what you bring what
you ask for is your approach what do you
ask for oh yeah if you know i have both
sides i can switch i can turn it on i
can turn it off so that's what you're
asking for you're asking for the
business
yeah yeah yeah you need to fight you
know now what do you think he's been
training for how long you been training
now maybe oh six months six months what
do you think is he gonna win or lose all
right
i will pull it off you think he'll take
a win
i think so wow have you heard him say
that before he's being nice on air i
think
no i mean he doesn't seem like the type
to lie true yeah
if you ask me this maybe two weeks ago
let me say ah let's let's retreat dies
right now it's throwing a dice yeah and
it dies yeah
but for a few days what he's been doing
you know
he show up don't get me wrong it was a
hard work yes yes i just started yeah
at the start even though i would say
maybe a month or
five
a month ago if you ask me i'm like
no you can't this kid's going to die and
no he's going to die yeah yeah
yeah i'll just say right away you're
going let your wife be next to you
[Laughter]
say goodbye yes
wow
for now i think yeah you can pull it off
okay that's really interesting that's
how that's how you know we felt the same
way at first
you've seen his opponent he's a big guy
strong
and we're like he's gonna die like we
love you buddy but you're gonna die but
we also feel like recently he might have
a chance yeah yeah okay interesting yeah
i don't want to say any of my
shortcomings are completely my fault
he's the best coach you could get i was
what why would you i'm not gonna why no
no not that's not blaming wally for your
shortcuts
[Laughter]
yeah it was a rough starting point
because i wasn't like you know i was an
athlete prior so
it was hard
so was he one of the worst you've seen
in the beginning
so what was it that was so shockingly
bad about him in the beginning i would
say um
he doesn't uh
he doesn't know his body oh it doesn't
connect
right this will go down
one leg
start and then
whoa
even though i would say a lot of people
right away finish training
they were like
you're gonna get him killed yeah
they were worried about that they're
worried about him they're like you're
gonna get him killed
it's gonna be dead i like people used to
tell me it must be paying you a lot
yeah yeah
now
apparently is there some kind of stigma
about these youtube boxers that you guys
don't want to get involved in that
because you think it's a circus or
something there's no circles because you
know all these youtube fighter because
okay
my own
battery they have
they have ends but it's like
you you haven't you have power you don't
know how to use it
it's different between because to take a
shot in the head
because if you take one take two the
third one it may be a wrong punch coma
right away people people can lose life
it's what he's doing even though he's
doing it as a youtuber he's a everything
take risk don't get me wrong
but
risk that you can avoid you try your
possible best to avoid it
but you know he's dead because
he's just about getting hit in the head
because even though you don't go to coma
you may go home start feeling a deck you
may stay forward concussion brain damage
so you're you think these youtubers
aren't just they don't know what they're
getting into they don't know why they're
getting i see well most of the
smartphones we know what they're doing
they're actually trained
they're trained for it
even though it's one time two times a
week they have the actual a fighter to
train them so they're training
underground like training working out
you know
so
but people is taking two weeks they've
never fighting their life yeah three
weeks and they're putting their self
into uh it's not good he's not i see i
see so you you're basically you respect
the situation in that boxing ring
there's real danger and you need to
respect me and be prepared
yes
so have you so i'm actually curious
about your like we know he
he might win but i mean honestly who
cares it's abe i mean you're more
interesting than him
you know
yeah
by the way he says uh
he says you're way harder ass than the
other trainers he's seen he says like uh
like for example
some of the other coaches are really
nice and hype him up and he's like my
coach calls me a [ __ ] idiot
he tells me i'm going to get killed
yeah that's good and he likes that no i
i i like that too [ __ ] up i would tell
you [ __ ] up yeah
i feel like i'm definitely one of the
most prepared because like last
was it two days ago whenever we were
sparring he told the guy who's a lot
bigger than me bigger than brett it's on
my watch he looked at me i want you to
kick his ass he told the other guy just
to beat me up
and how did that go how do you do it i
survived it's surprising
surviving he cut it he got his defense
up even though you get his ass ripped
he put it off he's like yeah that was it
that was the goal right right there so
we patched the test yep yeah endurance
you have to face it because this
because if you can't face it right there
[Music]
how's he gonna manage yeah also he's got
the
his opponent is training super hard too
yeah oh you're not impressed yeah
nah he's not about weight lifting he's
not about you going to the gym and
lifting he's got muscles you're not
impressed by that yeah that doesn't okay
so so you're not impressed by his
opponent
don't get me wrong
uh perfect uh prevent
pro issue if you can but we are smart we
will be smart you know i'm not worried
it's not how big you are you know how
big you are okay
it doesn't always be comfortable yeah
yeah no absolutely there's no judgment
you ever just be walking next to him
just keep him on his toes
[Laughter]
[Music]
so you were born in nigeria is that
right yes and you grew up there yeah
so how long did you live there i think i
was 19
okay but 19
yeah 19. and your name lucky boy which
is your boxing name has to do with kind
of how you grew up there in nigeria yeah
so what's what's the
backstory uh lucky to be alive yeah to
be uh you know
be especially
you know alive you know
and uh lucky to be oh yeah if you told
me when i was back home i've never
stepped my foot in the u.s
united states i'm like nah
that doesn't happen
so what hap what is there specific
instances where
you like almost
died or or was there something that
happened oh yeah yeah yeah what's this
[ __ ] what was it like
no we you know not not like now now
everybody got a guns but back in the
when i was living you lit you land in
the street
there's no going to school
you know
my you know my my bro my brother there
used to be a
gang leaders
your brothers yeah yeah my friends
that's all we know it's like living in
south central
that's a you were in nigeria so you grew
up in a nigerian gang
i said we don't call it gang
we call it a
neighborhood boys the neighborhood yeah
we found these are neighborhood these
are our territory
if you come from that territory you stay
in your territory if you cross that
border i see and everyone knew that
everybody knew that and so i swear
unless you can get killed like that
and so um
was there frequently violence ah really
violent yeah yeah we don't play yeah
don't play
and so you grew up in this kind of
really
really kind of violent gang
uh
gang
culture
and you um
at what age did you was that all the way
up until you were 19
yeah yeah yeah i thought the life i know
and so how did you end up leaving
nigeria
boxing
oh
yeah
so boxing got you out of it no boxing
wow if not boxing i'll be i'll be under
the ground wow yeah unboxings
so then
where at what point are you when when
are you boxing in nigeria i think i was
in
1617
we have situation happen in my
neighborhood then i have to go to
another neighborhood for me i went to
another
you know another city
for a while then i just
just okay
i'm on my own now
just
how to beat people up with no weapons
like oh i'm good in weapons everything's
a weapon right yeah
but i just want to know how to use my
hand with no weapon and that's where our
boxing came but when did you actually
start boxing i was 17. 17. yeah
and what was there was there a boxing or
a gym or something in your neighborhood
or yeah there is no much
but we have
a stadium okay i would go to a stadium
yeah because out of and if i go to the
stadium it's like getting out of my hood
out of my get out of uh
south central come to beverly hills oh
really it's nice yes nice day oh bless
crime let's see let's fight so go there
you know because all over the place cop
is always around so how about how do you
get invited to fight at the uh
at the uh arena
how are you
how did you get to be fighting in the
arena in nigeria in nigeria yeah just
come you just show up y'all show up to
the fight
is happening you show up and you can
just get in the ring
guarantee whoa yeah and so you were from
the streets
you know we have uh you have a
reputation
so people are like oh we know this guy
he can fight let's see him in the ring
yeah he's a knockout killer killer yeah
yeah you know he's called starkiller
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
so you had a reputation were you like
the muscle of the neighborhood boys yes
yeah you were the muscle yeah so when
some someone needs to get dealt with we
send in
killer
i'll try my best oh my goodness gracious
so is that why you're lucky boy you
encountered a lot of you put in a lot of
situations where you could have been
gravely injured no been dead been dead
yeah yeah yeah your wikipedia said that
you learned to run in a zigzag from
being sure yeah
i've been shooting many times that's
insane yeah it's normal
so you learn to run in a zigzag
because you run in a lot straight line
you're done yeah you don't yeah you know
you don't run straight
did you learn to run into zigzag after
being shot out or is that just what
something you learn on the street you
learn industries yeah you don't want to
run straight so who's shooting at you
police other gangs
you may be your friend he may be police
too yeah anybody so you know
have you ever been shot
not shot at yeah yeah but a bullet never
hit you never eat me because you got
that crazy zigzag
what dan yeah he's lucky
lucky boy
yup have you been stabbed or anything
like that yeah many times many times
many
times
so tell me tell me about uh
the first time you were stabbed
yeah i expect it is normal i'm scared
what i ain't scared i expect it is
coming oh you know sometimes you can
just sitting down maybe some may walk
through your behind your back and
breathe really quarter on your head and
stab you right on your neck why would
they do that just because you're part of
the gang maybe because i'm different
it means it means i'm sleeping they're
coming sleeping so you don't want to be
slipping that you're in someone else's
neighborhood yeah or you know you sit
down they lost your mind oh oh oh you
know
yeah oh that's [ __ ] up oh you don't
want to see you have to be always alert
behind the wall can i ask you
that amount you're like you can never
get caught slipping do you feel like
even now as you're older and living in
america do you feel like that kind of
paranoia still that's part of you you
let it go totally yeah yeah wow you know
but it depends on
the neighborhood i am
if i'm uh like even though you're in
u.s if you go to south central if you go
to ingo wherever you go sure there's
some direction yeah yeah you have to
know now
i'm not sleeping
but you can go to beverly hills close
your eyes
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're walking you
can come to hollywood yeah you still
walk around but you don't want to get
too
comfortable right right you know you
depend on this
sure so you've been stabbed you put
you've been you're the you're the
enforcer
so you had this reputation on the
streets of your neighborhood
for being this really good fighter so
one day you decided to go to the stadium
and jump in the ring ah no i just you
know i went to the stadium no
you know i went okay i went to the
stadium just
just to see the stadium you want to
watch just to watch yeah and uh
a security was right on this stadium he
knows me from the streets got it you
know my reputation then he said look
david where have you been for
a year now
oh i just
i said no
he's already died down
and he said what's up what are you doing
and i saw a nigerian team they're
getting out i saw a lot of people with
green white green
show everything neat i said who is this
are they a footballer they say they're
worth going to all african games
they're going to
maybe somewhere all african game
i'm like okay what did they do they said
they represented
their boxers
and i looked and i said i will kick
everybody out
these their boxes yeah he said yeah
these guys you know they're trained
they're gonna beat you up i said what
then we know we joke about it then
okay then you talk to me then
he has another guy who worked there who
is a professional
who is a professional fighter
who is holder he's a professional so he
came yeah i know we talked we intro he
introduced me to this claim
then we talked about it like he said
this guy
he called hands and he's a
bad boy blah blah blah sorry
the boy said okay try your hand you just
saw this patrol he said truman i said
pick one you pick it he said throw your
left bum right away if he said
[ __ ] wow okay he said [ __ ] right away he
said you
can't do you have money can you pay the
train i have a trainer that will train
you
right i said nah i'm not stable i'm
living you don't have money yeah yeah
you can't do that
then
i said but maybe in a week
i may get some money so he take me to
the trainer
until i was in the national institute i
said he introduced me so the trainer
trained a lot of
different bad boys we even hired me
see this is my neighborhood yeah another
neighborhood where people with leaders
who control uber guns who work for the
red
the like major jaws all those ones so he
trains them he trains him interesting
right away as we go to him and he asks
me
we talk and he tried me for one day
and he said if you can live this street
then
you're gonna be a
good boxer wow then and i'll leave it i
i didn't live live you know i live then
i train in every day so how did you end
up being able to afford to pay for the
training i didn't pay oh he did it for
free
so but now i'm paying him
you're paying him back now yes that's
very nice yeah i'm selling money all the
time because because he's your guy he
saved your life
wow
that's amazing
so he decided to train you for free
because like he saw that you were so
talented or is he just trying to help
these neighborhood boys out oh no he's
sorry i i got power oh
this this this dude can box yeah you
come back you want the boss he can no he
got power if i teach him how to box then
it's going to be a problem
wow i start knocking people's hearts no
so so you start training with this guy
how long do you guys train for
maybe three months six months every day
every day and you start throwing me two
people who've been training for three
years above me and knocked them out wow
yeah so you start training three months
and then you start doing real fights
three fights yeah get in the ring
knocking them out immediately
right like mike tyson back in the day
just destroyed her
a little
but we're talking about first round
knockouts so how many times are we doing
these first round knockouts
when i was amateur yeah
maybe i only have one loss oh okay
out of how many fights forty seven five
damn
lucky boy
that's amazing and what was that lost he
just caught you no i didn't go down like
we finished the fight you went the whole
way
and that would you live for a round
really how much you always go for round
wow did that surprise you that it went
the whole way no no he was a good
fighter
not to judge people were they scared of
you to fight you i would say no no
because they train i train yeah but if
you from the street people who don't
know me
they don't know who they're fighting
right yes yeah and so you've got about
you got 46 wins or something right
amateur and then when do you make this
leap to being a pro boxer i i went to
australia
so how did you get that opportunity to
go to australia oh i was representing my
country
so a guy here about me then he invited
me
from nigeria to australia there's some
kind of like uh
international competition it was like a
precursor for the olympics wasn't it
yeah it was like oh yeah it was like a
prior step we're going to uh come away
yeah australia there will come a weight
game there in australia so i was part of
the train and nigerian team
and so you were an amateur boxer still
yes okay so they put together a nigerian
team
to go compete in australia
what were the other guys on your team
like all like pros or a bunch of people
oh yeah amateurs okay later on when you
turn professional then you become your
own you fight you know
just your name
your country your position
okay so you guys go to australia to
fight so what happens there i love
australia yeah australia is beautiful
beautiful was it shocking that was that
the first time you left your country yep
what was it oh no no i've been
um
i won't say european or american well
i've been on all african continents yeah
yeah i've been south africa i've been uh
was it the first time out of africa yes
so what was it like arriving in uh
australia yeah okay even though right
there where you're telling me i can i
was just shocking yeah it's shocking wow
i've never heard by the country i don't
know about the country i just said okay
so far he's out of africa i'll give it a
shot
come and see then i went there i was
blown
wow what city did you arrive in
melbourne oh okay
and the food the people everything is
crazy
to me to me you can tell
two you can tell what you get yourself
into they don't play
whatever they say like
in a book
rule
the most strictest country i've ever
been mm-hmm what they're like straight
to the street like they
[Music]
what do you think about americans
compared to australians
you have your own opinion you can say
you can scream
is that different than in uh back in
nigeria
oh [ __ ] you can speak your mind there
no no if you scream too much homie get
pissed off just shut it right there wow
yeah he may well he may it may i may be
working you may look me wrong
and i walk up to you stab you
you yeah because you look at me wrong
you would stab me if i looked at you
wrong
i stayed in africa
you're nothing i just walked in yeah
that's crazy yeah yeah so are you back
when you were in nigeria is there are
you always scared just scared for your
life no yeah a little bit you live day
by day we don't look about it we don't
think about tomorrow yeah we don't want
to worry about tomorrow we live day by
day what is going on right now
maybe a year now it may not be there in
two hours
when you were training in the gym in
nigeria did all your neighborhood boys
were they supportive or were they
jealous
no
no no i'm the only person now they're
they're supportive my name is coming out
out of the hood
my name is
coming outside so they're proud of you
they're happy for you wow so even though
sometimes if i don't have money they're
like oh [ __ ] i can walk to any
restaurants eat
like i'll pay for him he's champ
he's a fighter that's awesome
so you arrive in australia
how did the fights go
it took a while because uh first time i
went to australia i don't fight
because i was just checking the country
out for three months oh you lived there
for three months wow three months first
so what did you do during those three
months do you train first train worker
the trainer because this is the first
time meeting this guy i've never
spoke to one person in my life i'd
realized
that
you know
everything is different back then and so
how was the training at the in the
australian gym compared to in nigeria
more
more technical i see yeah more
african you know we got
bones
majority of us can punch i got power and
we go hard
so how was how was that to move to the
mental game for you all right i'm
adapting a little bit yeah yeah you're
trying to get there yeah yeah so you
you're there for three months training
you go back i'll go back and then you
come back i don't really want to go back
right i said to the rhyme i said no i
didn't go back to her i said no hell no
[ __ ] that [ __ ] they forced you they
forced me to stay there i said would
bring me back i said no yeah i don't
care what i'm going to be pleased
i'm not going i left i left for maybe
two days i didn't come home
then he called me on the phone bring me
back he said go home i'm bringing you
back because if you stay here it look
good they won't be able to they won't
let you back in they won't let you back
in yeah and they're like okay
then i'll okay all right then
all african game is going on in my
country
and i just went on beat everybody went
to all of wow so at the stadium there's
the boxing like tournament oh tournament
we represent our country okay germany
france they all came there yeah we have
my country
from olympic who fight they stay here up
to today
and you fought there real fast
you beat it you won i won you won the
whole tournament when your tournament i
wanted i
wow
so right away get back from all african
games
my australian visa is ready
oh another year wow
then i won so were you happy you went
back
on top of the world okay are you winning
money when you win these big tournaments
yeah a little bit maybe they will give
you dollars they'll pay off with dollars
so you have a little money at this time
no
you but we don't have uh
you is how you come it goes yeah easy
comes up yeah yeah
i see
so you win this tournament you go back
to australia for a year yeah then and
then what provisional day and then you
turn professional
wow okay
okay so you're starting your
professional career when i was 20
i think 21
21 or 24
young man
lots of experience
i tried you felt ready but yeah yeah yes
and so how did your first fight go
knockout you knocked him out first round
his professional record with knockouts
is pretty impressive too it's like 28
knockouts or are there 22 nothing
altitude nor car
knockout being like a straight up
on the floor
sleep
you're the sleep you're the sand man
why why do you think it is that you're
so powerful i think i'm just blessed
it's not like you just you're just
gifted you're just blessed some kid that
just
there's something going on
it's not like uh i train for it or some
people they're just gifted i think
interesting yeah you just know how to
throw a punch
right you know i'm me i'm a straight
shooter that's interesting that's an
interesting talent yes if you if your
head is not there i'm not gonna shoot
this shot
he's solid i've never seen a human as
solid as him his like we sparred once i
mean he was just training me
and he just had his arm out he didn't
throw a hit and i accidentally walked
into it
to this day that is still the hardest
i've been what walking into us still
still faced was probably that what do
you think about that does that sound
right yeah you learn
you learn how to move he was telling us
how he sparred you once and you hit him
so bad his head got knocked out but you
i didn't know you walked in you
basically hit a parked car maybe i guess
so no he's a setup i set him up for it
because
i know you're always walking now he
learned oh okay you were trying to
punish him yes yeah you don't walk up to
people okay
i did get i did get lucky though with
one uppercut and i thought he was being
taken
he said he got you with a good one yeah
yeah one just one
and i i was telling the other coach i
was like oh he was taking it easy on me
and then he came out of the ring he's
like [ __ ] i would never let you
touch me
so he hit you he got you with the
uppercut oh yeah you're going okay yeah
how's greatest power on um from one to
ten it's like one honestly
one
[Laughter]
that's funny but now he's getting there
he's destroying punching school now not
before
oh my god
the worst you've ever seen when you get
home please give me your wife let her
talk to you i want to speak to her i
just talked about it talk him out of him
talk him out of it
he's told me so many times not to do the
fight when i first started he's like i
think you should walk away but that's
actually really sweet that like you're
you're trying to protect yeah exactly
yeah yeah because i've been there i've
done it i know i feel yeah i know i feel
yeah so i and i know the risk it takes
and if
i mean you got almost knocked out by the
man's stationary
right
he thought i was going to come back in
after the first time i sparred he
thought that was my last yeah it was so
surprising he thought i was yeah
he's a good guy
he's committed yeah
he got a
soul
boy he doesn't like to hurt nobody right
if he hurts you you may feel bad yeah
but uh we got to get him past that yeah
yeah yes yes
all right so you're in australia first
professional fight first round knockout
is it how long does it keep going like
that where it's just boom boom boom
knock out knockout knockout
i i think i left australia with record
of
18 and no 16 knockout
18-0 18 yeah it's a zeus with 16
knockouts 16.
golly
so how are you feeling you must feel
like the best fighter in the world
that's how i feel i came here i said
okay
okay so you're in australia you're like
i'm the best fighter in the world nobody
will touch me
and then how do you end up going from
australia to america ah i think uh you
know if you're a boxer you're gonna know
names okay james you're gonna hear
people's name big stranger names people
are starting to know you in the
professional world or you travel for
fighting
people
people out here people may not know me
but asians
asian in that part of the world yeah
they know who i am because i want one
belt for asian pacific oh you wanna hold
a title
wow
nobody will have to let the title go
after two years nobody will challenge
you
whoa nobody you're like i'm not getting
the ring with you even though the
champion on the doubt
is dropping the belt because they fight
a kid
a kid
if i want kid who win the bell he said
that kid was tough he's from a japan
tough kid he gave him hard time he said
until i fired that kid
i will fight that kid first before i can
fight for the title
i fight the kid i know the kid in the
third round he dropped the title he said
no i'm not fighting
no i'm not fighting
so you were the king of that whole part
of the world southeast asia
yeah until like come here like so then
you're like i conquered this
i'm gonna go to america kind of thing so
who invited you over there my wife is
the one who taught me about uh america
like let's come here oh at where did
where did you meet your wife i was
straight here okay so you're married to
an australian yes yeah oh wow my wife is
so strong incredible she make me
australian and she dropped booty tickets
i said let's go to america i said what
so where he said let's go for your
career you know just for me i had to see
and go on oh like a vacation
oh so first you guys went on a vacation
yeah okay interesting where did you go
we came to vegas i said oh vegas i said
no i said no i don't like america
vegas is crazy then i call my homeboy
you live in college you know come to l.a
i came to l.a vegas you didn't like it's
just like desert it's weird it's hot
i'm not gambler
i don't like gamble yeah so you go to
l.a i came to illinois where i came to
l.a i said
yeah this is where i meet wow
that is where i get it from
lax i went to la senegal passing google
downloading from hollywood you know yeah
from the uh las yeah coming towards
hollywood yeah i went to la senegal
mm-hmm
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah inglewood i smell
wood from there i said okay this is what
you do wow that's it
so what is it you love about la it's
like the world ah shane i love the
everybody's everybody from all over the
planet
that's right food and we all get along
we get along wow
you know we know like uh all these
we all you know switch to each other if
he asks for help someone will help if
that one will not help that one will
help you
you know and uh
the weather the weather is amazing i
like everything so i don't know what
what was the weather like in nigeria
where you were running a lot oh really
tropical yeah
humidity
yeah
you
you can rain eight months in a year oh
wow it rains a lot wow wow and australia
just hot australia is hot summer is hot
but the winter i can't stand it cold or
too cold for me you're not used to cold
weather all right yeah we don't we're
not we don't do cold weather here in l.a
either so
what was it like your first winter when
you felt like cold like hours
i went five o'clock they said you would
get used to it i lived there for six
years i said i ain't getting you
[ __ ]
when it would it like freeze over and
snow and stuff where you live you know
you know but sometimes it gets to -0
degree okay so it's
it's
called
ah my hand no my finger numb everything
now
i get grumpy
interesting
so you came here on vacation you liked
it you went back to australia yeah then
i i came back again the second time or
another vacation
i know for another training camp for
myself so you found a gym yeah in los
angeles
where we're at now oh the same gym
you're training now yeah
so how did you get a hold of them did
you contact them no i just flew in you
just flew in yep went in saying hey
did they know who you were they don't
you told them about yourself they're
googly they're like you're like i'm a
champ i have a title over in southeast
asia i don't care they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care they don't respect it no
yeah asian and it's true because they're
like this is a different world
yes and it was
it was and this is institutional boxing
no matter where you can fight on planets
wow if you've never been here
so did you come here being like
with still that confidence like i'm the
best yes yes you're like i'm the best
boss
because it had been true your whole life
and from nigeria to australia nobody can
stop you yeah
until i get you so you get here you go
to this gym
why did you go to that specific gym
because they have a lot of world
champion there okay you heard about they
have a reputation a lot of talent wow
freddie roach training oh a lot of
talent and he's a dog house
when he got there you know
it's the real deal this is a really dear
so you get in there you start training
what's it like training fighting yeah
the first four street they want to kill
me right yeah and then later because you
were already well conditioned you were
very experienced so did you get
challenged right away when you went to a
little bit yeah a little bit you're like
oh [ __ ] yeah i was like okay
you throwing a punch at people yeah you
have to move your head you have to be
slick
you have to move right you have to know
why you move all that stuff coming
together
[Music]
so the first time you fought kind of
like a north american boxer like a
really good fighter what was that like
for you was it kind of did it kind of
your confidence to leave you you no you
wake me up walk you out because the
first fight i would fight united states
i was cocky as [ __ ]
i was like yeah this kid he had 10 loss
oh he wasn't he didn't have a good
record he won 10 loss yeah he went to
win i would beat him with one hand yeah
until i got into him
with him i like oh [ __ ]
he was good yeah no he wasn't that good
but he wasn't that bad he wasn't that
bad too right i thought he's terrible
right it wasn't good he wasn't so the
skill level
way higher than what i expect right
because i communise him i thought i
would just speed on him so you did you
beat him i knew that uh knocked him out
too rest in peace
rip sleep down uh he woke me up because
i think
that's the first time in my life i've
ever been sitting on the ground oh he
knocked your ass down he does not knock
me out you dropped me he dropped yeah he
dropped me because i was showing off
oh i was doing a little demonstration
up oh oh my god all my cousins keep
telling me to do the ali shuffle and the
match i'm like my coach will jump in and
beat the [ __ ] up
yeah no alicia
no no leave the ali shuffle for ali yep
yep
he's not he's not here i'm big
you don't know how to do it [ __ ] you may
get you [ __ ] up so don't do it yeah no
shuffling shoveling it will take a lot
of many years before that will come
right
so the first professional fight
kind of surprised you a little bit but
you you're victorious yeah so how many
professional fights by the way how did
you end up to be per to be able to
permanently live here ah because
my kid is born here i know oh so you
guys you guys came here
and you had a kid yeah oh so you're
australian your wife from australia
you've got you and your family are here
and how long have you been here in
america
uh 12 years wow beautiful you have one
child one kid or more than yeah
i have two boys wow amazing
and um
so how many professional fights you said
you had 12
uh four uh
in the u.s 30 oh in u.s only yeah
18 and 0. 18-0 in the u.s no no 18 i
know when i came here so everything
has a
14
i'm not sure
yeah i was a yeah 16 or 14 fights okay
and did you lose any here in america
yeah five wow and what was the first
loss like for you
first floor wasn't it lost to me it was
a rob you guys went the whole distance
and the judges went against him i gave
him to the
i dropped him two times interesting
jessie vargos is his name
he's the you have a lot of uh he's a
famous fighter oh
famous okay mexican
he trained with floyd is everything big
name that's pretty incredible you went
the distance with someone like that on
tv
so people that was a big fight oh it's a
big fight
people are up to today people like no
you don't last they'll rob you wow
i've seen it on youtube and people in
the comments are all saying that wally
got robbed yep wow what do you think
happens when the when it's like politics
it's the game you think they intend they
knew you won they gave it to him yeah
because i can't sell a ticket
right you can't bring more it's a
business
it's a business they say we we this is
better for business
yeah if you win it's better for big
business this kid is africa he's strong
he's he beat him up but he doesn't knock
him out
and him he have a fan base so show me
the eye everything i when you fought him
though you could tell this is this is a
really good boxer um
yeah i think yeah you were unable to
knock him out right i dropped him two
times right two they counted for him one
time they only account for him one time
that's why i know the quality
they didn't even count it as a knockdown
they did not understand they say they
said he dressed
right
you're like [ __ ] yeah yeah you know
it's [ __ ] you're in the ring
and so the second fight or the second
loss
was there ever a moment where you really
felt like i lost two true yeah
did it really shock you to lose the
first time no i know how to take a loss
the first one i'm like
sir you know they say you fell down
you don't stay down you get
back up you stay fighting keep on
pushing so i it will happen in life mom
and dad lay he wins some he lost some
yeah he did
matt tyson it wins up he locks him yeah
so if you know how to take a happiness
of a win
when the loose come you have to be able
to take it because if you can't take it
if you come then it will drop you you'll
be on the floor right ah no all right
you win some you lose some that's the
way life is did you ever forge any kind
of relationship with any of the
competitors that you fought with like a
mutual respect or anything or was it
kind of just you go to your camp i go to
my camp
respect as in
like did you ever have a relationship
with uh afterwards you're like that guy
beat my ass oh no i want to talk about
we just know we just hug each other
respect right
yeah yeah keep your pushing i go nuts
i go west you go south yeah
i see
and if you come from the same
neighborhood if you fight each other
when we become friends we train in the
same gym we learn from each other
we don't hate each other
hatred yeah there's no like even though
i've seen a lot of people know i've
knocked someone out
and i feel a little bit like uh damn i
hope he doesn't nothing he's okay he's
okay yeah okay and i know some people
are like no if you die you die i don't
give a damn you don't like i don't like
you i hate you yeah he died now i don't
care
jesus
i'll go home
and maybe if you were to punch him would
you hope that would you say if he dies
he dies no or yeah yeah you like gabriel
okay good
he's a good guy all right appreciate
that
why is it that you retired what happened
uh
it seems like just a few years ago yeah
you retired yeah because uh i
boxing is a dangerous spot absolutely
and uh if you know your your body
your body may be right your mind
may not want it because you know i've
been professional for 15 years and
when i when i was young
if i could have if they gave me the
opportunity
that i deserve i think i will make a
little bit noise
but
because
the opportunity wasn't there and they
gave it to me too late too they gave it
2019 fight three times
right so i get enjoyed and i've been
boxing for 15 years and i see your work
for your health yeah you want to protect
your brain i have two brain uh
concussions you have two
be careful if my concussion kicking i'm
biting your finger
[Laughter]
and so it seems like you had a pretty
successful professional career you made
a little coin yeah yeah i'm good for you
and i win if i built two so you got the
belt from southeast asia or in america
american too which belt did you get
numerous wbo
what's it wbo what is wbo style
world boxing organization wow
how did abe end up getting this uh i
always wonder how did how did such a
such a decorated boxer end up your
trainer maybe
i just looked around i heard about wild
card and i went inside and the lady said
are you okay with uh dealing with
someone that's tough on you i was like i
could yeah i'm used to that i come from
a strict family
give me the toughest you got i may have
underestimated a little bit
no i'm very i'm very thankful for wally
i would not have gotten here without him
so
take a long drive
you know ah damn i'm excited you excited
to watch this fight yeah i'm interested
it'll be good yep he told me once that
he feels like i've gotten to a point
where if he gets in the fight he'll call
me for back
would never
i would never
like when i started he told me i can
punch him when he's sleeping
[Laughter]
different trick every day just to call
make it nah
teaching method hey let me ask you this
i have to change
i have to change oh
coaching someone as incompetent as him
may have improved you as a coach oh for
sure
maybe you should be maybe he you should
be paying him
i'll pay him i took my [ __ ]
yeah this this guy's putting you to work
eh oh
different oh i have to use his wife i
have to use a dog
sometime i would go on my wife would say
to me you too ash on him oh his wife is
your wife works there too no
what did she see you do them
he was being nice that day too
well i gotta say uh i know it's two i
know you have to you have to leave
but i've enjoyed talking to you 100
it's been so nice learning that the
american dream is still alive is that
right yeah you feel like you're living
the american dream oh for sure
thank you thanks for taking care of our
boy 100
thank you thanks for coming in no maybe
we could check in after the fight i'm
going to get your analysis
win
he's never going to talk to me after the
fight
maybe maybe
but yeah i think you can pull it off
yeah for for sure thank you i'm looking
forward to it well wally
thank you so much it's been it's been a
joy learning your story
and uh
well there you guys have it
hey i'll see you later i'll talk to you
later thanks man that's awesome i'm
gonna walk out with one we're still live
so you guys go
you guys
there you guys have it
baby's in good hands eh
well what a story
how is it that a world champ is training
av that's
it's like
i mean it's awesome it's super
interesting but
that's so funny
so what do you guys think of wally
[Applause]
i'm in wally world the audience uh the
audience loved it right oh yeah super
interesting yep
what a great story what what an
incredible story
fam wally they're saying
my family family
wow
wow wow wow eh
oh god my back is killing me you guys
from wow
i was holding bruce
uh like all night i have him during the
night and i just you get in these really
weird positions when you're feeding him
and he falls asleep you don't want to
move so end up sitting in these really
weird positions for hours yeah my back
is just so jacked
so what do you guys have any comments
any thoughts
i'm feeling pretty good for a b after
this you know
over the last few weeks i'm i'm coming
around on the idea that abey's got a
good shot and i think he's got a really
good shot well and like he's got like
one of the best fighters i mean one of
the great fighters coaching him he's got
a great coach and he's got a good
attitude about it i mean we've all seen
it how hard he's been working and
everything and
you know we've been consistently hearing
from these people that actually know
what they're talking about like him and
idubbbz coach that
you know
the pictures of eb's opponent hundar
muscle don't look intimidating but yeah
it really boxing isn't about being you
know a beefcake it's it's about skill
and it's about being smart from the
rings i loved i loved all the stories
about how trying he's trying to get lena
to
get ap to quit
yeah people are saying i did a good
interview you did you did very well um
yeah that's super interesting that's
weird to uh see people saying
[Applause]
i'll tell you one thing i wouldn't want
to [ __ ] with wally man hell no hell no
he said he was going to stab me if i
looked at him wrong
i would not want to [ __ ] with that guy
at all
it's just funny the way he's saying he's
like i'll stab you if you look at me
wrong
he's like okay
that guy's probably seen some just
horrible things in nigeria growing up
that like we didn't really touch on the
specifics but
it's incredible he made it out of there
real real cool guy really what a guy
oh you're muted people loved his story
that was a great man great guy you don't
think he's going to want to talk to you
ever again after the fight you know i
was just i was saying because i'm gonna
embarrass him so bad
you're trying to embarrass him no i'm
saying if he's embarrassed by
embarrassment oh i see yeah
he'll go no contact
wow that was awesome i'm glad he came in
you know yeah
so
that's i guess the first part of the
oh someone says people are loving my
interview skills well that's nice thank
you
it's pretty easy when uh
i'm talking to someone as interesting as
that though
[Applause]
i didn't know he had like belts and
stuff he's got two belts maybe yeah no
it's impressive i mean that many
knockouts i don't think that's common
for a professional
only like the greats yeah
you gotta spar with him you gotta go you
gotta once was enough for a lifetime
i was telling dan without spoilers in
the scene and attack on titan when
someone's head gets blown off that's
what i felt like when he punched me i
thought he ripped my head straight off
my neck oh my god yeah
wow
so um
we got actually a full show to do here
we have zero sponsors today so shout out
to the members
members members members
we love the members
thank you for being a member
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you
today we are talking about uh
oh hassan has kovid
so i don't know
did you is there any way to do an
episode on thursday or did you hear
anything back from that dan
no
so there's no
way okay that's good
so thursday there's no show because
hassan
got kovid i think he's avoiding me
if you ask me
[Laughter]
could be
i think he's lying just to avoid coming
here
can you buy
it well he showed the covetous with the
two stripes i wonder if you could
probably buy a positive covet test
you know i want to put it past him
i love that
oh also mental health update a lot of
people have been telling me to do
wellbutrin with my lexapro
and i'm happy to say
that yesterday
we got started on wellbutrin
give it up
supposed to help me lose weight
and have more energy
nice
just hit them
wellbutrin
lexapro
omaprazol
turn it up let's go
hey
okay
hey hey hey
thank you for everyone that suggested
that
all right let's get to some good stuff
um
by the way i made a joke about i was
like is he a little too old to be going
as johnny
and y'all poo poo'd me
i was universally poo poo'd i did not
have one ally in that comment well rain
wilson apparently is a fan of the show
because he stole my joke
is he old enough to be referred to as
john depp 70 000 likes
that's a banger tweet
that was my tweet that was my joke
human fecal matter
so there you go i bet you guys feel
silly
johnny johnny
yes papa
yeah theodore likes that song which is
why i always say it
i don't get that one and it's not like
just the way you know there's a song
johnny johnny yes papa eating sugar no
papa telling lies no papa
open your mouth
i don't know why this one took off the
way it did but now it's in like all of
the popular kids channels
and different iterations
uh theodore loves it though yeah my
nieces are always singing it too really
yeah it drives me insane it's not it's
just not a good song
also i find it weird like the whole
lying and concealing like i don't think
it's a good lesson or anything yeah
now i've talked to lean about this too i
don't understand the meaning of that
song
so johnny johnny yes papa he stole he
stole some sugar or something yeah
johnny johnny yes papa telling lies no
papa
eating sugar
first of all who eats straight up sugar
that's [ __ ] weird
like even for a kid that's weird
yeah actually so i talked to a
psychiatrist yesterday
and i guess it's normal to gain like 10
20 pounds on lexapro
i've gained like eight a 70. he's like
you have gained substantial weight
was he he was alarmed by that like well
he was like that's definitely
look here's the deal that's a lot that's
a lot it's a lot
well he was like is it just uh he's like
do you have any other health con
conditions that are making you gain
weight
no i don't i mean i've had checkup
recently
and he's like
what's your what's your appetite level i
said voracious
endless
the black pit doctor gorge yourself
until you're on the verge of vomiting
yeah right
exactly
but anyway i feel good i got a
psychiatrist so what does the well-boo
butrin do like what it what is
it well does it help no but it's a
really interesting medicine apparently
it can it's both prescribed as
a weight loss medicine and an
antidepressant
but it does it's a different
antidepressant than lexapro because it
affects like uh
dopamine
and not sarah
got it and it's like an upper like a
slight upper apparently
but
like lexapro you have to taper off
otherwise you'll like
have crazy
body shocks and stuff
but this one apparently you can just
stop at any time so it's it's an
interesting drug
but it's very common to take them
together in fact he told me they're
making
a new one that's both of them together
in one pill
it's like a speed ball speed ball baby
is that the one where it's md and acid
no speed ball is a heroine in coke
oh that sounds like a horrible combo it
is it's killed a lot of famous people
have died of doing that combination have
you ever heard of that one where it's
acid and mdma
oh yeah
yeah that's candy flip i've
been candy flip
i've been to candy land you candy
flipped
oh yeah i prefer the hippie flip which
is don't do that by the way yeah don't
do that we remember bounce drug use it's
horrible it will ruin your do not do
drugs
ever under any condition i had a
terrible time every every time it was
yeah every time i've done mdma it's been
so horrible
flipped
it's been totally flipped
um
did you guys hear this that machine gun
kelly and megan fox are drinking each
other's blood i sure did i didn't know
if you had seen that yet i was gonna oh
maybe bring that on yeah i saw it and
i'm just
i don't know it's like guys you don't
have to lie to kick it
you guys don't have to try so hard just
[ __ ]
just be happy and
hot or whatever you guys do
you don't have to be drinking each
other's blood like it's overcompensating
yeah i don't know what's worse just
watch netflix
what i said i don't know what's worse if
they're lying or telling the truth
like if they're trying to say that they
are when they're not or they're actually
doing it
it's a coin toss she referred to it as a
as a
like a ritualistic thing that they do
which like made me raise an eyebrow a
little bit
so
yes thank you here's what she said
she says so i guess to drink each
other's blood might mislead people or
people are imagining us with goblets and
we're like game of thrones drinking each
other's blood
it's just a few drops but yes we do
consume each other's blood
on occasion for ritual purposes only
okay
and it's controlled it's like let's shed
a few blood drops of blood and drink it
he's much more haphazard and hectic and
chaotic where he's willing to just cut
his chest open with broken glass and be
like take my soul so [ __ ] cool
yo by the way have you heard i'm in love
with the emo girl that [ __ ] is hardcore
demonic he's chaotic and cool and rocks
have you listened to have you listened
to it backwards
he's crazy dude
yeah yeah exactly
he's not he's stopping doing rock he's
not doing it anymore
thank god the world rejoiced
he says his next album will be rap again
the rap world probably isn't rejoicing
they don't want him either nobody wants
him
well apparently that's not true because
he's a
top selling artist so people want him
somebody somebody wants his music and
apparently they're not even kids because
didn't you say sam that when he was
people were begging him to come down and
they were like in their late 20s
well that's just embarrassing
so there you have it they're drinking
each other's blood
by the blood of the lamb by the blood of
the lamb nobody asked first of all and
yeah i think there's a 50 chance they're
lying about it
because like when you're home with your
significant other
do you really do rituals i think you
just watch netflix
like when you have that free time
right you don't do rituals i don't think
so
but he's doing rituals
it's ridiculous
shame on them
we got a new
banger
from our boy my favorite comedian right
now
hoping that he'll be hosting the oscars
this year coming up next year
yeah i'd like to see will smith slap
this guy
yep
yes
oh
[Music]
this one got a lot of likes so somebody
tried to tell me i'm wrong
he's grown on me
there you have it
i don't know why that
that one's just so ridiculous
kris jenner got busted for being a dick
to a to a servant to a driver i i'm i'm
shocked
i just want to talk to you for two
seconds i'm just saying hi to my
daughter i'm just i'm just on a deadline
here i just have two seconds can we call
her right back
i love you baby give me a kiss and i'm
gonna go sir
can i ask you to leave us alone for five
minutes
wait what did he do what does she mean
by that she wants to be alone on
facetime
um
she's making an announcement to chloe
that she doesn't want anyone oh she
wants the driver to leave the are are
they are they not moving yeah they're
stationary so she's like can you get the
[ __ ] out of the car for five minutes why
don't you get out of the car
i just want to do something real quick
thank you when my mom wants the driver
out of the car and to have a private car
it's actually not that bad though is it
it there's more get to work that's what
i thought yes there's normally only a
handful of things that play through my
head
did somebody look up somebody's pregnant
there's a crisis
bye baby okay here we go
is his window rolled up yes but the
trunk is open close
[Laughter]
excuse me sir
she's on tv you imagine she'd probably
even be even bigger of a b word if she
was
not on camera would you mind closing the
trunk for a moment thank you so much
it's not what you say it's how you say
no
hi
well that was it the announcement was
that her sister is getting engaged
so she's in a good mood but she's still
being a b word
close the trunk because you think if
you're in a good mood you'd be polite so
i think we secured the date you wanted
really
i i mean the whole family's despicable
and i i
i really don't care what anyone has to
say
don't come for me
go for them
close the trunk close the trunk
honestly not that bad though
for all the twitter backlash i've been
or i've seen people bitching about it
i mean of course she's a she's a b word
this is a surprise the way kris jenner
rudely demanded the driver get out and
close the trunk remind me why i quit the
service industry
having money does not mean you can treat
people like that honey
first of all there's no doubt that she
was like a major b word but
like
it wasn't that bad in my opinion was it
am i am i crazy close to trunk
or to be like a scandal
no i'm not a scandal not really
i mean unlike we talked about they
probably are happy that there's backlash
because it's just got people talking
about them again here we are talking
about closed trunk
like their uh their show what is on hulu
yeah i saw it's like the biggest debut
of anything they've ever had hulu yeah
i ever fee you know i'm a reality show
junkie you know i'm like rock bottom
[ __ ] i just can't i'm not i've never
watched that show i refuse to watch the
show
do it sam do you watch the show am i
missing out is this a good show
i used to but i haven't seen it in
forever i have no idea what's going on
so
not really into it i just can't get into
it you know
because i might the way that i like
reality shows is like trashy people
being trashy
and i feel like they're too concerned
with their public image and they're real
and like i'm not interested in like ooh
she's so famous and successful i want to
glimpse into our life kind of thing
i want to see women pulling each other's
hair
yeah
i need the raw like bachelor
exactly yeah
i need to watch nobody's lose like ruin
their life forever yeah totally by like
yeah people are saying it's a good show
honestly it's not that bad full
disclosure i've watched the first two
episodes it's not bad it's probably the
new season or just in the new season
okay but i used to be a huge uh
kardashian fan on one
well that was when i was going to school
with them
so you watched the first three episodes
no good first two was the third one out
yet
okay so someone said selling sunset it's
this uh
real estate show on netflix
i watched the first season it was pretty
funny just because like
the two owners of the brokerage are
these little munchkins and they're so
creepy they only hire like young
beautiful women and then they date them
and they're the two little munchkin
popsicle kids
and they're just so disgusting and
creepy and i and so like i like that it
was centered around that
but the new season is just [ __ ] awful
i can't watch it it's like so bad you
guys that one's a netflix one
yeah someone's saying ultimatum i've
seen that i haven't seen that one i'll
watch it
there's a person in selling sunset that
is fighting in amy's fight
wait what uh yeah i don't know graham
stefan he he started off he actually was
in selling sunset graham
yeah he was kind of like a side
character i think wait the guy who's
fighting michael reeves
yes he was not in selling sunset what
are you talking about
he was
what
yeah he was working for their firm yeah
what hold on i got it there's
compilations like season one of selling
sunset just graham stefan
i know that for a fact what
yeah when was he ever in the show
i watched their podcast and he was kind
of a side character yeah there he is so
they fired all so he was the only dude
well i guess look at this outfit bro
what are you
[Laughter]
i'm telling you so there's these twins
and they they hire only young beautiful
realtors and they'll take like any bozo
like if she comes in and she's
attractive and young and like has no
experience what this show really shows
is how
being a real estate agent is the biggest
[ __ ] job in the world sorry todd
sorry zach it really is
it's just so [ __ ] [ __ ] job
comments act or no
nah
nice
selling sunset rocks i love that show
you like the new season no i think the
new season is
i've only seen some of it but it was a
little it was kind of sad because
krishal stauss with her whole divorce
and everything
uh i don't know i just thought it was
kind of sad but the oppenheim brothers i
love thinking you said munchkins
they are short kings they're
they're not they're they're not kings i
hate them they're gross they hire they
have sex with their they they're
disgusting little freaks dude
yeah do they
do they have
is it more than just christelle styles
that was dating uh one of the well he's
dating one of the girls now that's like
one of the plot points yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then she reveals he dated two
of the other girls previously
oh
interesting
anyway whatever i don't i i watched the
first one this one it just feels like
work watching it
but anyway
uh we have a few things first of all
love needs to eat some some
stroofin
yes we're gonna talk about we have a
beans on toast update part three
i do want to talk about the lebran
family
there's a lot going on in this dock eh
there's a lot
a lot going on
so there was a whole debate going on
with love
he made a tweet that said i will eat
anything that's the most liked
is that right love did you tweet that
yes or no i did tweet that on my
secondary account yes okay
okay
and
here's with the tweet tomorrow when i
wake up i'll eat whatever the most like
reply is
now what is this this this is your
response act or are you showing receipts
i'm
i'm showing receipts because if you
remember last episode uh here it is he
denied that
the fika fish won
1800 correct
1800 bro to 1300. so what so how can you
deny
so at what time was that those
screenshots that doesn't [ __ ] mean
[ __ ] though wait when did i wake up do
you know
it's irrelevant it doesn't matter
love is your guess letting the [ __ ] out
in this situation so so your argument
love is that
this was posted after you had already
woken up i'll i'll tell you exactly what
happened i tweeted that tweet before i
uh went to bed right
and when i wake up i look at the
i i checked the responses and the
the beans were
more liked
prove that i go through that is the
proof of that there's no way the beans
were more like than that there's no way
in [ __ ] well
i don't know how how it could possibly
like
prove it but don't say like don't say
that my evidence is wrong because it's
all there and then and then he decided
to come up and say that the tweet never
existed of the green bay okay he
couldn't find it tell you well i'll tell
it go ahead but that would never that
would never make me win i just thought
that tweet was removed
how why would
because i looked for it and you didn't
haven't seen it so the tweet hasn't been
removed right no it's in the screen it's
in the screenshot just an honest mistake
i i honestly thought it was removed
yes okay fair that's fine but so you
ended up eating the beans on toast
but do you feel like a little bit like
you owe the world as some stressing
because i feel like i got weaseled into
paying you 500 bucks like zach said for
something that you already owe the world
right no
i didn't mean to send out uh here i made
a my own imgur album
why is it not love
receipts you gotta send it not in uh
discord because stupid discord so
exactly when did you recall when you saw
this the some strossen posted in
response because i would think that
would be one of the first responses and
based on the amount of likes that it has
it would need time to populate that many
likes
yeah i i he he's saying that
the green beans won
and
then he decided just to eat the green
beans which is total [ __ ]
you know look i love i love you you know
yeah sure but i've seen i've had to eat
my words on stuff too and you know
i [ __ ] eat a lot of gross [ __ ] and
you got to pay the piper on this one my
friend but i really do think it's
backwards here because you have no proof
i woke up
let me let me finish please please
please please you have no proof that the
beans weren't more liked
like that was that screenshot is taken
probably five or seven hours after i
even like replied with my beans post
then i sent you the imgur album could
you bring it yeah i've just pulled it up
here so
okay so here we see a couple first of
all that one we got a winner that was
replied before or
earlier because the beans were always
more alike than the fikka fish that is
not approved i gotta stop you there like
anyone can write that at any time no i
have no proof i wasn't prepared to be
put on trial yes
if you're gonna enter that as an exhibit
i'm just gonna strike it down right now
i think what i'm trying to say though
and it is fair is that zack is the one
making the accusation of wrongdoing here
so the burden of proof is on the accuser
zach needs to provide i did i mean he
exact clearly showed the photo with the
some strosin with way more likes
when was that screenshot taken
what does it matter what cause love is
saying the cutoff was when he woke up so
he woke up looked and at that time what
are the chances that it didn't have more
likes by the time he woke up i agree and
i spent all my time on social media but
i have no reason to lie here well let's
see your other evidence i'm calling such
a horse i've just gathered like as much
as that backs me
as possible i
had i wasn't prepared to do this so
let's keep watching here i'm watching
so i have more people like agreeing
right now he's showing these three
people here's the second tweet hold on
let's let's just see it let's hear him
out
okay oh hey i made it in the screenshot
also zach i can vouch for love even
though i really wanted him to eat it he
is correct at the time the count stopped
beans on toast did indeed have more
likes because i remember being
disappointed by it i checked myself
hannah marie aka loves alt exactly
[ __ ] exactly who the all right you
got two pictures on there you got one
thing no i have a lot more let me talk
let me [ __ ] talk
oh you you have you have two options on
there green beans
the [ __ ]
green beans or the fifa fish yeah why
why would anyone
vote for the beans right yeah okay okay
okay but okay no that's compelling it is
compelling i have a smoking gun so
please keep talking i have something
else
hold on i'm going to read these two
reply keep going zach i saw the thread
beans on toast had more likes simple as
that don't disinfo this one and one more
comment um because mike this is the
person when young fika woke up
case closed leave love alone this makes
that's the person who made the beans
post that is the bean poster that's
interesting but they have a vested
interest yeah they have a vest if it was
this
i'm only here for the truth
yes yes i know but i'm so glad you said
that okay well then go ahead very
interesting
dms these are dm's
what is this what is this name okay hold
on before i read this before i read this
i need to confirm
that this is the person that posted the
this is the strong the strongholds i see
their name i see their at name
so can someone pull up the original
screenshot
i mean here it is the tweet here it is
yeah this is the person yeah
this is the person that did this post
so they said
so this is love messaging i was
wondering if you have any input on this
whole beans fish drama at 3 am pst do
you believe there's any way your feeka
fish
reply had less likes than the beans on
toast reply
and then the poster responded i think
for most of the time beans on toast had
more likes than feek of fish the last
time i checked maybe 30 minutes before
you posted the beans on toast pick the
beans on toast still had more likes i
believe you when you said beans on toast
had no likes when you woke up
oh wow that's case closed it does sound
like they're just being nice yeah i was
jack amazing that person he probably got
the same response in his favor how is
this case closed please explain this
good evidence i provided proof there's a
number 1800-1300
i think what zach's saying which i agree
with is i can't imagine somebody voting
for the beans instead of the fish
okay but can i add another thing sure
the reason i thought it was deleted was
because i couldn't find the
reply right so i looked through the
reply was gone so i assumed when zack
also didn't see it he said it has less
like i think it actually like got hidden
like the algorithm like this elon musk i
know it sounds dumb i know it sounds
dumb like but i know i want to speak for
you that happens to me see it i can
never i think the figa fish just got
better algorithm and got liked
and that's that's that look i i don't
know how what else i can do to prove my
innocence here i don't even care that
much to prove my innocence it's just
there is that's wow 90 love zach you are
this is not going your way buddy well
you took a poll yeah i just initiated 90
percent i'm sorry i i
i i was on your side zach but this is
this is very compelling evidence though
though love
this is very wrong well i'll eat
however
you still got to eat the [ __ ] fish
yeah and i gotta pay for it
right that's the problem
love can be like you know what ethan can
i get a pro bono yeah i'm sorry to cause
you a headache let me just do this for
you can i get a pro bono fish eating i i
cannot do it for free i don't know dude
it's horrible and inside too i'm gonna
okay absolutely [ __ ] up my room okay so
we have negotiated privately me and love
the terms of eating the feeka fish
for those of you that don't know what
strom
uh
sur stroming is
it's pickled
uh fish
that's fermented it's like rotting it's
stinking it's widely held to be one of
the most disgusting foods in the world
uh in terms of smell
it's used in traditional swedish cuisine
and when they use it they boil it for
hours to get the pungent smell out of it
is that right love
no so what they do uh they actually like
open it outside because it's gonna like
squirt everywhere it's gonna
it's compressed and it stinks yeah
uh and then you like pour all this uh
the stuff out and then i guess you put
it on like i actually made one here just
to show i won't eat it together but you
make like a flat bread dance sorry dan
can you put him up on my screen so i
can't see him
sorry go ahead love
you put some uh some like creme fraiche
and some onions and stuff like that
and then you put the fish on there okay
so that's what i guess people like seems
nice
i don't really like it at all
yeah so
me and love have negotiated the terms of
this if i'm gonna put 500
i'm going to need to get my money's
worth
that's a lot of money right
so what we've said is he's got a fresh
can can we see the cam please unopened
yes
now what he needs to do is
where do you get this just a local
grocery store do you need to go to a
specialty place no i drove around like
for an hour to find the because i
i want to find the exact same can you
guys had to make it like completely fair
right it took me a while to find this
one show it on show it on the bottom
camera where your keyboard is yeah
that looks right
this should because i didn't want any
like argument over anything so i i found
that babies grabbing our can right now
to verify did you find it
[Music]
yeah so basically what's what we've
agreed on is that fresh can
in his room with the windows and door
closed
it's so evil
yeah it's very evil but i'm
i'm fine with it love i'm sorry oh it
might still be another yeah
with the windows and doors closed and
then he's got to eat one whole fish not
a tiny one a respectable one so you've
got to show it to us
we'll approve it but but one whole fish
of respectable size and keep it down and
at that point you'll have one five
hundred dollars and my response love
love i'm sorry for doubting your twitter
your tweet oh don't worry about it i
don't know but i understand that i i
really hope you enjoy this fish my
friend oh i thought you were being nice
now previously it was ian that down the
whole thing yes
exactly can you try the piece and spit
it out what happened yeah it made me
vomit
not bad
i'm gonna try to open this i'm opening
i usually people oh wait hold on don't
open it yet we're not ready we're not
ready does he have his muddy hoodie too
hold on don't open it
no i'm not opening okay so
did you find the can uh oh it may be
downstairs i'll go check it's not a big
deal i trust love it's fine
[Music]
all right so how are we going to do this
so take the can out
what are you doing with this what what
what there's a give me one sec i gotta
he's putting on like a poncho
he's gotta cover up okay but you gotta
out you've got you gotta open it out in
the open open it
i want to see it like on your desk as
you open it
with a can opener
i mean
now what is the poncho for
well it it remember it's like
pressurized it like explodes he probably
doesn't want to get that on his clothes
is that the reason
oh sorry i took my headphones off for a
second now why are we putting on a
poncho
this is a garbage bag i'm just taking
any precautions
this will permanently stain [ __ ] all
right so please take the can out and put
it on your desk so we can see it wait i
can't open it in a plastic bag no
i want to see it we gotta see
we're doing an entertainment show i
gotta see what's happening but it's
gonna
come everywhere in my room well
it's 500 bucks
i have nothing to say
let's see the can
it's gonna take
oh oh yeah
[Music]
okay so is there is there any
precautions i mean i want to see you
open it right so i'm not sure what we
can do about that
[Music]
we got to see it
oh it's gonna i i'm sitting literally in
my closet with all my clothes
oh boy
well the smell the smell was gonna it
was gonna happen no matter what
well it wouldn't come like juices on the
clothes can i not open it in the plastic
bag
wait hold on oh there's a fly
um it maybe maybe you can do it away
where the bat i mean
oh
uh
[Music]
can i do it like this
yeah that's okay
that's okay
all right so love is an open fortified
angle
so the juice i'm open it at a four to
five
that's okay degree angle yeah to
reduce the liquid up here
all right so let's do it go ahead so we
are making our first incision
[Music]
he's it's very pressurized so he's
struggling to break the
heel there
that's an interesting can opener
yeah looks like military grade kind of
i think i'm good
did you make your first incision
yeah so it didn't squirt everywhere did
it no no i
the 45 degree trick did it all right so
let's see so you don't need the bag
anymore
yeah okay great so let's see this thing
so is there any odors happening at this
moment yeah very bad well
okay
now we all remember quite well the odors
of uh
of the fish
yes it filled this whole studio
bro [ __ ]
unfortunately love got the slowest um
can opener
as well
i feel for love now love can you narrate
a little bit what's going on in there
[ __ ] i'm not going to be able to open
this [ __ ]
is it really hard to open it
yeah
um
can opening technology has not uh
interested how convenient
has not reached sweden yet
this sucks bro my [ __ ] god
people are saying i'm david dobrik
thoughts love
no
you can back out at any time i mean
what the hecking dog maybe we can cut to
something else no don't cut keep an eye
on him
no funny business you're going to switch
it for a can of tuna
oh
the camera is falling
oh this is so convenient oh now here's
the smell here's the switch right now
this is a lot of time for him to switch
it
has the smell permanent can you show us
around the room how small is the room
[ __ ] bro this sucks
this really [ __ ] sucks i can't do
that here
what sucks that you can't open the can
or the smell
both that i have to [ __ ] sleep in
this smell
okay i won't give up though no i believe
you at this point
i i don't know i don't like that we
can't see the can it's there baby is
questioning uh
that we can't see the camera i'm like
[ __ ] juiced
how would you describe the smell um
like a [ __ ] uh
toilet
toilet
all right so there's the can
i am so glad we're not living together
now man
so love is in the middle of opening a
can of sir strowman
which is rotting fish we we should come
to something else while i do this
what do you guys think cut or stay on
them that's risky because 90 of the
audience got finessed
where are we about to get finessed love
no i mean
well what did wally say uh no
he says you got to stay i mean can't get
caught slipping
yeah
yeah
how's the progress on the can opening
uh it's like halfway okay so we're here
yeah we're making progress can you tilt
the camera
yeah people are saying don't do it love
it's not worth the money thoughts to
them
at this point the worst part
the worst is over you think
am i [ __ ] god
it's okay just go ahead with the can
yeah i don't want you to get too uh i
love how he's overwhelmed there
yes sir garnet darn it so can you
narrate the smell the experience it just
smells like [ __ ] literal anus okay
so love is living in an anus a man or a
woman's anus
i think it's a man a man's is nastier
because there's a lot of hair
i think men just have nastier shits okay
okay so i got he got this [ __ ] open i
know my he's living in my anus to be
honest with you
fecal matter i'm gonna have to swap my
whole [ __ ] keyboard
all right can we see the cam please i
feel like this there's something
happening now
can you do me a favor now smell your
fingers
because i remember
specifically smelling my fingers after
touching it and it was really bad that
smell does not go how's the finger smell
how does that make you feel
it makes me feel delicious
it's quite it's quite remarkable isn't
it
it's fantastic oh i feel for you man i
may have missed this because i walked
away for a second but did you prep your
dad did you let him know the house is
gonna stink
yes he said no to open it inside i said
i i'll give you 100 bucks
so your dad is getting a piece of the
action
yeah he said yes to 100 bucks
yeah
love love offered me 50. now guys before
you feel too bad about yourself about
this we've all done this we all done
this before our side as well we've been
through the gauntlet love wasn't here
inside
yes inside it was inside our studio in
your room in your outfit of sorts
so it looks like you got it open there
right i didn't get paid 500 bucks now
can you turn it hold on turn it towards
the camera so we can see inside
i'm in the middle oh yeah that's a good
one
can you turn the can towards the camera
please love so we can see
oh i see it's not open okay yeah so this
that's a respectable one
can you guys see yeah yeah swimming
yeah how we should take a shot of the
liquid
uh i thought we
no i'm just i don't want you to do that
i don't that's just
all right so so hold that up does he
have to down the fish yeah yeah of
course yeah just like wait what'd you
just take off it
are we allowing that ian you're the one
that ate the whole thing i mean i'm just
saying i didn't take anything off of the
fish
yeah yeah i think you got to eat that
dude you just took off the best part
i want that level of approximate slide
so basically i i approve of the size of
it that's definitely a respectable one
so do i uh
and you didn't eat the tail right
for the record i'm like a raccoon what
love or what can't what are you bigger
i said i ate everything but i'm like a
raccoon like you know no it's funny ian
ate it all he ate it all if you want to
take just the fins out that's fine i'll
accept that yeah i'm gonna hold the fin
yeah i'm gonna like
make this and just eat here
um you're coming in a little quiet so
before you attempt it i just want to get
make sure the mic is situated
oh
yes didn't want to get juice on the
shorter microphone all right is
everybody ready
love is about to undergo the gauntlet
and prove his swedishness to the world
this is the sir strowman challenge
uh 500 on the line
got to eat that whole fish
so whenever you're ready love i go ahead
and take it away
i don't know if i can where's the guts
by the way
it's right here okay good
good good excellent
all right bottoms up i'm [ __ ] shaking
dude swedish pride baby just remember
that swedish pride he did say no problem
when we talked about this yesterday he
was very confident yeah i am overwhelmed
by this but i gotta do this just
remember you don't have to do it
if you quit now i'll pay your dad off if
you quit now i'll pay your dad the
hundred bucks so you don't have to pay
him yourself can i drink take a drink
before or no
sure you need a drink
don't do it on camera though oh it's
just water
uh it's soft yeah yeah yeah i don't want
to get him
what is that soda with no bubbles
okay he's going in whoa oh he took it
right out he put it in took it right out
all right he's gagging he's gagging hold
on if he starts puking cut away in we
can't show that okay so he put it in his
mouth
and then
he took it right out and started gagging
and then he tried again
and now he's spitting he's gagging
definitely struggling are you out love
i'm out oh my goodness oh my god love is
out whoa oh
should we cut away should we cut away if
he really is gonna puke you you should
okay he's not on okay he's not showing
him well i'm staring at him he he wow
he's really suffering he's got the
that [ __ ] it was [ __ ] worse than i
thought okay put it put him back
are you feeling not you're not going to
puke right
uh
i'll wait if if you if you do just let
us know
yeah
so what happened you put it you put it
really put it slid it down the whole
thing and then
you abort it eh
yeah it's too bad the flavor caught you
off guard
yeah this makes it all the more
impressive that ian downed that thing
man i am so
freaking impressed
that ian gobbled that down i have never
seen anything like that in my life and
do you have a newfound respect for ian
having ate a whole fish
oh i already had a lot of respect for
ian right you can't you can't get any
more ian is a man of god so you looked
up to god's great maybe you need to do
that love just look up
yeah that will find that power
well love i'll pay i'll give you a
hundred bucks to pay off your dad so you
don't have to go ahead and yeah
i have uh i feel like i've disappointed
everyone watching well you gave it a
valiant effort i mean it is what it is i
mean
i am a little surprised i'm not i'm not
i'm not trying to shame you into doing
it or anything love but love
love is one of the most like intensely
competitive people i've ever met in my
life so i i
i am a little shocked to see him back
down from a challenge especially one for
money right he also loves him
it [ __ ] backs out on me dude she just
came straight up
you know i i think your mistake may have
been going in so you base you deep
throated that thing i think ian took
bites you know i think you went to maybe
too big no ian ian took the whole thing
just dropped it is that right ian cam
just provided uh the clip if you want me
to pull this up yeah let's see how ian
did it yeah
i think i ate it like a cartoon cat
yeah oh so maybe that is how love
attempted it yeah here it is
the whole thing down bro dude ian you
are
you are men among men
you are a giant
i'm british man
though
you're like it's pretty good but uh it's
almost as good as a as an irish crumpet
as a scottish eggy bakey
just seeing that and smelling that made
me puke my brains out i'm shocked i'm
shocked how do you do this how how how
do you do this i'm blown away you are
true warrior and you're wearing the same
hat as you are today that's true do you
want it to second round i'll get in
above another 500 on it you know what's
so funny
is i don't think i've worn that hat
since and i thought when i put it on
today i was like the last time i wore
this was like ain't that nice does it
smell still
i don't know they might have a little
odor left hey will you eat one for 500
since you're in that hat you're gonna
make me we don't have any we don't have
any i think we do
would you do it
i don't think we have any okay is that
your way of saying no
i don't people hey people are saying i'm
sure
by the way people are saying ethan this
is some dubric level [ __ ]
yeah
no dude i'm pretty sure it's we've all
done literally food it's literally a
food item yeah well do brick level [ __ ]
is
uh making people do dangerous physical
stunts that they're what are you talking
about
just enjoy the show
we're putting on a good show we're not
entertained
exactly are you not at a time i don't
really want i really don't want this to
turn into a thing
obviously this is just funny it's for
fun get down please
so well
is the smell slingering you've got the
windows open no it's not no
you said it i guess i can open you can
open the windows for christ's sake of
course
you don't have to live in it
wow well he gave it his best shot i mean
ian is an absolute beast watching that
clip over again i don't know how yeah
yeah the difference between me and and
dolbrick is that i pay them at least
true that too you know he doesn't even
you guys have health insurance
right i pay you guys and also eating a
fish and 10 surgeries on your skulls a
little bit yeah there's a bit of a gap
there maybe not for our audience but
it is different guys the thing is the
thing is there's a little a little touch
of david dobrik is good
a drop of dubric is good
too much dubrick is bad it's just like
machine gun kelly you know a goblet of
blood too much like there's no little
drop yeah just a drop for ritual for the
riches yeah you know jackasses are great
it's a little drop of madness is good
yeah
how you feeling love you okay
no no i don't want to make the situation
worse
don't worry about them dude don't don't
worry about them are you gonna are you
about to yak
i ordered it
oh my god
well i think i mean that should be
surprising
multiple of
us puked yeah right yeah lots of puking
i think olivia and maybe did you yak in
your room or the bathroom oh yeah yeah
my room
into like a trash can
yeah
are you are you it seems that you're
kind of taken up uh by surprise by the
power of the assumed strowman
yeah
and is that your first encounter with
tsum stroman yeah dude no one eats this
[ __ ] it's not like yeah
people don't [ __ ] with this [ __ ] right
especially not raw they feel they that
[ __ ] they could be probably no they
don't cook it
but they
they put it with a bunch of [ __ ] i guess
but yeah it's brutal dude
oh interesting comment here
wait what are you eating wait go back to
ian what the [ __ ] was that what are you
eating oh i'm just eating anything what
is that
it's thin bread
oh it's a bread okay yeah you get bread
and you roll it up but now it's like dry
because wait i see i see i see love i
just want to say i tip my hat to you
still my friend for attempting it
thank you inside
somebody um
commented that um
uh there's an english dish called
jellied eels which is worse than
jelly eels
well let's put ian to the test
i've never heard of this before heard of
jelly eels the picture is horrific it
sounds vaguely familiar but i've never
had it ew
oh no oh no oh my god a bowl of eels set
in jelly oh
damn
i
i think like
it's too big
you can't eat this much nasty [ __ ] it's
too large of a piece yeah i couldn't
swallow i i was thinking i could swallow
it whole and that would be my strategy
like just close uh not breathe with my
nose and swallow it but that [ __ ] was
too big you did yeah it was big i said
yeah i was worried when i saw you dip
that all the way down there
yeah it's huge it was huge
so we've got to get our hands on some
jellied eels to put because ian i think
much like wali is kind of a
a belt holder i mean what can't he eat
do you feel you feel confident to take
on another challenge ian
man
what a great comparison you are a world
champ
uh
you gonna make me do this you no of
course i'm not making you do anything i
don't make anyone do anything do you
want five hundred dollars is that yeah
that's up to you i mean yeah i'd do it
for that there you go really
yeah i i can't believe that you would be
willing to to do it a second time
i personally have a hard time believing
that this is worse than the zoom straw
man but yeah i have that heart it
doesn't hurt too i'm seeing people in
the chat say no way is it worse yeah
but i think the smell got me though the
smell is it's all about the smell it's
all about because if if i got this [ __ ]
outside i
maybe i would have been able to eat it
but the smell is putrid yeah it's hard
to describe how just how terrible that
smell is you know i went in knowing that
that was going to be
the worst part of it and
unquestionably the worst thing i've ever
smelled well when i smelled my fingers i
lost it yeah
no it's next level
so ian are you any interested in doing
that kicking that back for 500 today or
no wait what the hell are you talking
about the eel or well well we could do
that but the zoom stroma oh the stone's
strowman oh
just because you have the hat on oh yeah
the the company
you know garbage disposal sam what do
you you i stunk last time please god
don't make him do it
i'm not making anyone do anything
please do not i just put the offer up
there and he could take it's available
to anyone his like mouth and beard like
area
smelled so [ __ ] bad for like four
days it was miserable
i didn't eat that [ __ ] but lena almost
took me to the hospital that day that
episode
i think because i have like a reaction
to soy milk so that
with the like hot sauce was killing me
on the way home i feel like my stomach
was going to exist
with the spicy stuff you're chugging the
soy soy milk it's a great episode though
so um okay that seems like a a pass from
sam ian
yeah she doesn't seem thrilled i don't
even know if we have the can i don't
know maybe i'm almost certain that we
have a can but you want to go find it
oh i think i know exactly where it is
okay
now sam he he said let's ask sam she
said no
and now he's going
man we're all going to smell like [ __ ]
could he do it outside
you're walking home i'm i'm sam says
you're walking home i'm confident
there's no can here i'm we did have a
can it was above the fridge downstairs i
just checked though i didn't see it i
don't i think it's where dan when dan's
feeling pretty confident there's a can
i remember when that shoot ended we were
frankly trying to clean up the smell
because the next morning we had a like
second episode of leftovers and we were
all afraid that hassan was gonna all
right right hate the smell so much
oh somebody said icelandic rotten shark
next i've heard about that
i wonder if we could get our hands on
some
rotten shark
sam how are you feeling knowing that
this might be happening
ian's walking home
but i'm not i'm not going to be near him
it's like cove it all over again you're
getting quarantined
14 days
i think it's fair sam gets half the
money because she has to deal with the
smell
well well i'll make a comment ian's
beard is much shorter than it was
yeah it may help still
it's still gonna like marinate in there
i will like it's totally is no i will
also note though last time when we did
this we were in a different location oh
he had found it or dan found
the [ __ ] can
that's oscar's finest search strumming
yo shout out to oscar
all right so we did this we were in a
different shooting location where we
could open
windows and things we do not have that
here
we opened the garage door last time oh
[ __ ] well listen i'm willing to sit here
and endure the smell
it'll be funny for the show
but again it's up to you and there's 500
on the table
i'm not pressuring anyone
there's a lot of people there's the chat
seems to be split should we do a poll
that's not
come on i mean there's a lot why bother
i mean that's just guaranteed what
there's a lot of people saying no i
don't know there's a lot of people
saying don't do it again you know
it's do i get any money why would you
get money because i'm just gonna smell
it i mean this is the worst part of this
whole thing come on
[Music]
no you gotta just sit there and do it
maybe i think i i think ian should split
it with me it sounds fair to me actually
you know what i'll put up 100 for sam
500 for ian 100 for sam how's that dude
sam king [ __ ] well ian's got to live
with him so i'm just going to give her a
little something to sweeten the deal for
we got to live with him until we leave
now y'all get you ain't getting [ __ ]
love is gone he's just out oh no
foreign
okay wait love where are you you turn it
off
are you okay i turned off my camera for
very special reasons are you yakking
still
yeah oh my goodness gracious
oh no
no sponsors today by the way i'm losing
my love of the game baby this is all
love of the game so far the yeses have
it but only it only 60 40. it's not
there's a lot of no's there's a lot of
no's
62 to 38.
well ian
what is your decision
can i go p first yeah go pee think about
it
100 for sam 500 for ian
no one looks thrilled in the crew i got
a point no no i want you to get your
money i'm i'm i'm in it get paid boo i'm
the only one that's crying because i'm
about to lose like a thousand dollars a
day [ __ ] no
episode with no spots forgetting how
like
i know but i mean we're all gonna be
subjected to
i want it inside
i just don't want to go to the gym smell
like a fish
guppy i'm not like i i just cause we had
a fika fish in the mix that i don't know
i'm not thrilled to do it i'm not
jumping to do it ian go pee and then
come back and give us your decision okay
okay we do we do need to
decide one way or the other at this
point
i got a piece so bad ian has to pee
so basically
thank you to all of our members for
essentially supporting my
[Applause]
very expensive
and then we have a we
here let's talk about uh do you guys
know the bad baby made 50 million
dollars in one year
on on off
or well actually no 42 million that's
nuts
what is going on here guys
that is insane
what
the f is she i didn't realize is she
like a sex icon or something bad baby i
she's just turned 18 i don't know man i
feel like it's a bunch of weirdos
waiting for her to turn 18.
so she made more doing messages that
means
that someone messaged her like a special
request
not necessarily that means she would
send out videos
in her messages
and you have to you have to pay to open
the video in the mail oh okay yeah
so subscription is just so you get free
stuff with your subscription correct
and then you get premium stuff she goes
hey you got to drop 20 bucks to see me
do whatever right so you have to pay two
times
for the premium premium correct
dude
usually the whole marketing is like
check your dms
um
that's where the good stuff is yo and so
the other thing
is that she doesn't even do
nudes it's like or i guess it's semi
nude right
from
when we were researching it correct it's
some topless stuff and
holy provocative risque photos i mean
listen i'm not surprised that she's able
to make a living here but 42 million
dollars you think it was like
like uh
okay list taylor swift or something yeah
yeah like an a-list celebrity
if she if bad baby can clean taylor
swift will make a billion dollars
on only fence i mean amaranth uh
she made she made a bunch of money too
amaranth's not making this much she said
she make a million and a half a month
right right
so bad at this rate bad baby must be
like number one on the whole site
she making more than like the ceo of the
biggest companies in the world
yo dr phil took the biggest [ __ ] l
on bad baby well also to reiterate what
abe said
she did join the site when she turned 18
like
right on her 18th birthday yeah so i
think there are a lot of like
weirdos in a way but you can get that
anywhere i mean
right but but they're watching they're
waiting right i mean she she she's been
posting since she was what 15 16.
so people don't know who bad but babe
it's this i'll show you she was the cash
me outside girl
cash me outside how about that
i always thought she was way older than
she is
like she always looks like five years
older for some reason
but she started a music career
and then she immediately went to only
fans like the day she turned 18.
golly
i just
i mean she's pretty don't get me wrong
but i just didn't think
i just didn't expect all this i don't
know
are you guys surprised by this or not
no it's definitely surprising i need to
get all my fans i'm about to show my
dick for 50 million
yeah i'd whip it out
it's interesting how only fans just
became kind of like a additional revis
revenue source for a lot of people
like if you're comfortable with your
body
and whatever feeling sexy
yeah it changed a lot of people's lives
a lot of people became millionaires in
less than a year
oh yeah
i think it's great i've said it a
million times it's so much better to get
this money
instead of going and working for some
creepy uh
pieces of crap like one company if you
look at what happened to uh
mia khalifa that's your name right yeah
like what'd she make like ten thousand
dollars for and she'd been viewed like
billions of times and you know the guys
who put her out there made her do all
this horrific [ __ ] probably that she
didn't even want to do
or that's what she says according to her
made all this money and now god bless
them all they go make their own cheddar
and they're powerful they can [ __ ]
live their own lives i think it's
awesome
rise up
somebody pointed out that you give away
the goods for free on uh that's true
that's true i'm a man of the people yeah
you guys don't even have to pay to see
me naked
yeah her videos uh mia khalifa got 784
million and she's only paid 12k
say that again her videos were viewed
784 million times and she was only paid
12k
damn yeah that's nuts that's nuts but i
mean good for her now i know she has her
own
business yeah
she's on off i think too right yeah and
i'm sure she's probably one of the top
but holy godly damn i'm just
people are saying my feet on off
only feet
people are someone said frontal lobe
doesn't fully develop till 25.
i can tell you i wasn't mature until
like my mid like 20s like fully matured
but what can you do i mean god lee you
know
[ __ ]
shocked by that
that's like if you just invest that
money in like the stock market sure like
she'll have like a dynasty you put 50
million dollars in the stock market your
like
great great grandchildren are set for
life
just from one year of showing titties i
might have to start hanging some dong
dude you gonna show that hog off
for that kind of cheddar [ __ ] dude yeah
i'd be curious to see how much that
could make
i actually i made an only fans like a
year and a half ago as a joke and i was
gonna post a bunch of photos of actual
fans like
ac fans but then someone said that on
our show and i'm like goddammit that was
my idea oh this code amico came on and
she said she was gonna do the same thing
so so then i had it you never got paid
i'd abandoned the idea i'm thinking
maybe like not
posting only fans but not what people
think on there no
it's been done it's been done i mean
bella well yeah
bella what's the
delphine has
did it
do you guys remember that dj khaled was
on only fence for a while oh yeah he was
just like behind the scenes right
yeah
it's awesome
with fat joe
[Music]
i want to see those two rubbing belly
then we're in
[Music]
but you know if i was like a hot well if
i was single and like shredded and
people wanted to see me naked like you
know it's like [ __ ]
i don't think dudes are getting the same
action as ladies but
i believe tyga is number six on the app
but he's the only wait does tyga show
dick yeah
yo tiger shows dick on the only fans
i'm almost
are you serious
holy crap that guy no way
the musician yeah
and he's number six
he was in 2021
yo
no way
wait seriously well i'ma type tigers
yeah he does tyga only fans let me see
what pops up
i have gotten used to i don't know
safe search off
but it is
off here i'll just do tyga
naked
i i i getting this i'm getting the oh
there it is
but that's a leaked photo that's not
an only fantasy
well he set it up his only fans after
that photo was leaked oh he's like screw
it everyone's seen my dick let's just
get it yeah some people speculate if it
was a clever marketing scheme wait it
looks like he's got like full
penetration on here what but
what
you just sign up
no no no
wait are you on the back end no no i'm
just googling it
there was a video that came up
and it looked like fried tyga's only
fans now already then
but isn't he isn't he is he married to
kylie
or they have a kid i don't know the
drama details he had a kid with uh blac
chyna
oh okay he's not related to the
kardashians
no he dated he dated uh
kylie he did dick he dated kylie before
travis scott did
i don't know why nothing's really
showing up
except that one leak to dick
but good for him holy god so there you
go if i
aaron carter was number 11 last year no
aaron carter yeah wait is that the the
main one or the like crackhead brother
the crackhead brother
he was number nine
i don't know if he's a crackhead but
the one who just shaved his head on
live yes right and then hair sprayed his
bald head that one so they're just
paying to see his dick huh
holy god
what the hell
incredible world we live in
what a world
what a world all right i ian your back
have you given it thought
uh
all right let's do the
500
let's do the beans on toast finale and
i'll and then i'll do it after
i'll do it at the end so ian has pledged
to do it
at the end of the show
i'm regretting going and getting this
can right now
yeah this is just remember you're the
one that got the can i know
you were gleeful when you came back
uh what what's the headline story
uh the timing uh oh tim
tim toole
got him yeah tim cool who i love the sh
he's like the biggest tool in the world
he keeps he keeps he quotes with a
keemstar
uh
from he called me out for my beans on
toast apology
keemstar tweeted that i hate gay people
because of my beans on toast apology
and temple reported on it
the slot bucket guy we talked about
saga of ethan klein by the way we did
we bought the uh slot bucket or one of
them there was like a 25
test one
so we're gonna try tim's big sponsor the
slot bucket
tim slot bucket pool you know what you
know what the problem is though it's
definitely not me
no
of course not so let's see what he had
to say
is a warning to everyone as to why you
do not try to pander and you do not
apologize
now what do we mean when we say don't
apologize are you talking about my beans
in toast apology
i mean don't apologize when you did
nothing wrong if there's something you
did that you think was wrong i guess you
have no choice but to apologize if you
regret just imagine that so just imagine
for a second
what if
i actually did think i did something
wrong
talk to someone that i trusted who said
suggested i think you should apologize
and therefore i did apologize
sounds like [ __ ] to me doing it boy
but i suppose you'll need to have a bit
of spine meaning that even sometimes
when you do things that might be wrong
you still stand by your sentiment but
can apologize for delivery
in this story ethan klein of
h3h3productions
loses his sponsors after he makes
offensive comments about the lgbtq plus
community leftist organizations and
cultural groups are easily offended in
which case you're going to be
apologizing for everything even if you
made a a passive joke
because of this ethan klein lost his
sponsors and it was actually a big deal
people were saying hey look man you reap
what you sow ethan had taken down
episodes of his podcast where he
interviewed jordan peterson jordan
peterson responded when the episode was
taken down saying i liked you but you
know rest assured you will be held to an
ever
to to an ever increasing standard which
you will not be able to maintain and
then they will devour you ethan klein is
once again being cancelled this time
because he really talking about the
beans on toe [ __ ] is this where this is
going
oh my goodness
he jokingly mocked his own apology and
now people on the left are saying you
never meant that apology well he's
actually true it i do find it a little
ridiculous that people are getting
really upset about the the joke beans
and toast apology
but i'm sure he's going to drive it home
to the absolute wrongest point possible
at all the only thing you can do is
stand up for what you believe in and
tell everyone else to shut up if you
don't like it don't watch it
okay yo he just did a hair flip he did a
beanie flip he's like girl if you don't
like it don't watch it
everyone else look at this hair flip if
you don't like it don't watch it
let me show you what a real hair flip is
like
that was sick dude little sass off tim
pool
you like that hair flip dan
don't like it don't watch it
[Laughter]
they love that that was powerful sassy
moment for temple
just to shut up if you don't like it
don't watch it don't bring it okay from
the left right up down religious not
religious i'm gonna say what i think and
feel and if you don't like it there's
nothing i can do i'm not gonna keep
trying to play whack-a-mole trying to
figure out what won't or will upset
somebody i'm going to say what i think
and cool dude
that's the [ __ ] you want from me in this
segment as we talk about how ethan klein
has no sponsors because he was cancelled
okay so i have we have sponsors we lost
some sponsors
i don't recall saying we lost every
single sponsor we lost some sponsors
i'd like to give a shout out to virtual
shield by heading over to wait is he
serious right now
virtual shield also it looks like a scam
website
now
i will never lose sponsors and now thank
you to slopbucket.gov
to
surfinginternetsafe.com why yes tim cast
has sponsors
bro that's the joke we made that yours
are like weird off-brand scammy slot
bucket [ __ ]
and uh this one's actually kind of funny
and a bit meta ethan klein loses his
sponsors
virtual shield has sponsored my youtube
channel my first youtube channel i know
virtual show will never leave you
and they now sponsor
well i don't really do sponsorships on
the tim cast channel anymore but they
still sponsor the work i do i've never
had this issue where literally look at
this
i don't really have sponsors on the tim
cass channel anymore yeah i wonder why
that was exactly what we were talking
about right
that's his podcast is it not
yeah that's his show why wouldn't he
have sponsors right so that's
so we were right he doesn't have
sponsors by the way look at the quality
of this website
this is like a hacker.png
i'm assuming it's a vpn service uh yeah
yeah i
can't say i've heard of that one but
maybe it's a legit one uh you know i'm
not sure
i mean look you've heard the same vpn
names there's like three that make the
rounds we're sponsored by expressvpn
yeah and then i've heard of like one or
two others that a lot of youtubers are
yeah
but i've never heard of this one for the
insurrectionists there's virtual shield
right for people that believe that the
mike pence should be hung there is a
virtual shield somebody said virtual
shield looks like an fbi honeypot
masquerade
bro
totally that's a great point and
tim fool's show would be the place to do
that oh my god that's so true
they've come and they've been outraged
and said you're offensive and i get
insulted and smeared all the time on the
internet go to surfing internetsafe.com
support a company that won't play these
dirty games and will provide you with
security yeah well i'm i'm happy to
announce my new sponsor um
where's this going um
discount uh discount uh
um
[Music]
it's a vpn plus slot bucket service
[Music]
okay what's the most
today i am selling
raid shadow legends
that's great shadow legend
that is the bottom of the sponsor thank
you to rage shadow legends who has never
abandoned me through thick and thin
the right oh yeah this this episode is
brought to you by the russian government
don't believe what you see in the media
folks
the recruit there you we are denotifying
ukraine believe that
someone uh sweet like tea said i used to
work for the company that creates
survival kits everything you guys
describes exactly how the customers are
yeah i mean of course you have to be a
little nutty to buy a [ __ ] slot
bucket
yeah adam and eve is pretty
the only other place i've seen the slot
buckets getting sold is on like those
like hardcore or even jim baker right
exactly like jim baker yeah exactly like
like a poc like jesus is coming down
yeah
this episode is sponsored by
uh
oh
blue chew like the uh child dysfunction
yeah yeah that's another one fashion
nova somebody suggested someone said
alpha brain sponsoring bobby lee and
andrew centino listen it's fine like i
get it get the paper do your thing
i'm just i can't
because i'm so vocally against all this
dumb pseudoscience [ __ ] i can't exactly
work with them but you know it's fine
this episode is sponsored by ace fest
get your tickets online today
it's running out fast
hurry you know flaming turd bag anyway
let's keep watching tim paul curie
here's a tweet from keemstar ethan dude
you already [ __ ] up
you're a news man he thinks he's news
he's doing keemstar tweets i mean he
knows who keemstar is
yeah well they're more aligned then then
they're not
on youtube unfortunately
inclined lgbtq plus fans were just
starting to get over how his homophobic
remarks get over his homophobic remarks
from two weeks ago
and now he memed his original apology
showing a lack of sincerity in his
apology in the first place now they're
upset again ethan hates the gays says
ethan do you agree with that
i'm sorry says keemstar so do you agree
i feel like he can't make up his mind
should i have apologized do i hate gays
what's happening his position seems to
be that
you didn't say anything wrong in the
first place and then you shouldn't have
bowed to the woke mob by apologizing
sure i get that on what you said but but
but now you also
made a mistake
by not being sincere about the apology
yeah i don't know it's just
because if i said something hateful
about gay people then i should apologize
let's see where he goes so here's the
original apology april 12th to my lgbtq
i think tim is doing drama because she
didn't accuse me of that he accused me
of doing drama and ruining and damaging
everything i think tim cool is a drama
caster now
two plus fans i am sorry for the
comments on today's show the
sexualization of gay men and the
grouping of tops and bottoms is a
stereotype that i will be trying to
unlearn apologies to the caller too who
i shouldn't have pressed and
appropriately hope you guys know i
always mean well well on april 23rd
ethan said
to my english fans i am so i am sorry
for my comment on today's show my
judgment of beans on how is this tim
cast this is a news show
this is crazy to me toast being gross is
a stereotype that i will be trying to
unlearn apologies to all english people
who i should not have pressed
inappropriately hope you guys know i
always mean well and now you have these
responses from people saying and and you
wonder why you are losing members it's
been a ride watching this guy's career
take off and then crash and burn people
have been saying that for like 10 years
by the way
you know
i think
like we were discussing on monday when
it comes to twitter people really do
attribute too much power to these kind
of things because
we're not losing members no we're not
the subs have gone down but the views
are the same our memberships have gone
up and it's really not that big a deal
it's really our views are good
our membership is good i mean we've been
losing subs
steadily since frenemies ended right
which is fine
but um
um
i do think it's
i do think it's funny how angry some
people got about that again
i guess part of the context for the joke
was that on the subreddit there was lots
of ironic jokes about people canceling
demanding an apology for my beans and
toast right
like i said when we talked about it on
monday if you had asked me
i would have told you people are going
to be mad about this
i thought i thought there there might be
a chance i didn't really i was like this
is just a lighthearted joke so like
who's actually getting upset about this
i thought it was funny
you know i made another i'm just i'm
going to start doing apologies every day
after every show
my last apology was for
to the scottish irish and welsh fans i'm
sorry for my comments and comments on
today's show saying you are the queen's
people is it disgusting and accurate i
was about to cancel you're the one that
said that no [ __ ] no i didn't you
literally said
what did i say
you said something about them being the
queen's subjects
well don't throw me i'm saying you're in
there with me but
well anyway who cares uh disgusting and
actors downplays your unique identities
i can and must do better i will eat
beans and toast every morning until i
like it which is we're preparing beans
and toast right now i can smell it
breadcrumb
but yeah maybe i should apologize to tim
poole or something this time
you know
there was a show i used to listen to uh
growing up a radio show that uh
they had a bit that at the end of it
they like had a running list they must
have had like a producer writing down
whatever they talked about on that
episode and then at the end of the
episode they would spend
like a minute straight just apologizing
for every topic that they talked about
on that episode that's kind of what i'm
going for yeah so maybe
if you guys could um
today to realtors oh that could be good
apologizing to realtors saying you're
worthless scum reach
[ __ ] bottom of the barrel right i
apologize to all of lucky boys opponents
um
who he knocked out i like realtors i
think that's funny okay realtors no i
went too hard on those poor realtors
you know
what to love the love and the people of
sweden i think the realtors really
deserve an apology more than anyone for
you know and specifically todd zacco
you don't have to
my dad
and among others among other things
ethan klein apologizes what the [ __ ] is
this website it's for homophobic james
charles comments on h3 podcast
there is no winning good sir ethan klein
there is no winning i don't think ethan
has any political positions i think the
dude i have no political position is
i have to be honest
on the back end of the bell curve you
know whatever he's he's he oh he's
saying i'm dumb oh a little does wait
does he know i'm eskenazi jew i'm at the
top end of the bell curve according to
their racial theories
excuse
me oh don't get mad at ethan for saying
that tim brought up the bell curve okay
yeah tim is the
i'm just saying bro
tim you think i'm dumb have you [ __ ]
listened to yourself just saying you
literally blamed the whole world for you
being single in your late 20s
he's on he's on the on the decline
you know all things come all things go
i'm sure that'll that'll be true for a
lot of people but uh he thinks my career
is over you know i've been on the
internet for a while now dude
like 10 [ __ ] years at this point uh
it's definitely an entertainment so i've
never been a big big fan of trying to
make an investment in an entertainment
career
how long will you be entertaining for
the the fupa guy with the double chin
and the hat
you know he was only a character that
was memeable for some time yeah and i
haven't done it in like five years
ethan made a great business move when he
shifted from his goofy youtube videos
into podcasting and started interviewing
people like show me your hairline [ __ ]
before you talk about my bell curve
let's do a hairline curve
take your head off show me your [ __ ]
dome
jordan peterson all of a sudden you had
what may have eventually been a new joe
rogan
he was edgy he was offensive he was a
funny guy and he was willing to talk to
people
why can't he accept that like
me being actually true to myself and
brave in the way he thinks is
knowing that i had that path line in
that career and going the other way to
be true to myself
he can't possibly see that there's only
one perspective in the world and that's
the joe rogan jordan peterson
tim
you know the internet uh what is it the
um
the
the dark web intellectual dark web
that's right
i was so jealous not to be a member of
the intellectual dark web
i'll be on the intellectual hair web but
uh
without tim
it's definitely not me
i think it is you
i think it might be
i'll keep playing hang on
maybe i am lower on the bell curve i
can't play this damn video
controversial can you grab that i like
that i'm lower on the bell curve
by the way that reference to the bell
curve is like one of the most racist
like white supremacist whole [ __ ]
it's so pathetic based on a book that i
believe the author of the study himself
has come out and said
like denounced and said you know it was
based off of
that the data was awful yeah but they
they love to bring it up all the time
yeah it's really interesting if you hear
anyone bring up the bell curve they are
racist i went to dinner with a
girlfriend i was
timple alpha male dark web genius
i went to a diner with my girlfriend and
was told it was a 20 minute wait
after only a few minutes a couple walked
in and was seated right away i
complained and left right away i don't
tolerate [ __ ] and i don't tolerate
people who think i should care when they
don't okay [ __ ] karen you're at a
diner bro it's not that serious
i just we've talked about this tweet
before but just a reminder of who what
this guy actually is what we're dealing
with here
you know he really drank the kool-aid
like it's so easy to just become a
reactionary punk
ass
and uh
talk about belgium
you know suck elon's dick on twitter all
day
sorry dude i can't live with myself with
doing whatever white nationalist
pandering you do
even though it'd probably be more
profitable
at the end of the day you know i want my
kids to be proud of me and uh
somebody here said uh they thought that
this tweet just existed as like a
backhanded way of telling the world like
i actually have a girlfriend
oh for sure right like it's like a it's
like a low-key brag like he didn't need
my girlfriend that had no relevance to
the story at all
yeah well if you're is he ever taking a
picture with her is he real
no he probably doesn't want to uh have
her be public because i'm sure she would
get harassed yeah that's probably
true
now he's not
he's not funny
why a little bit
but what i mean is he's given up on on
being this this the comedic edgy
personality because he's worried about
offending people he's given up on
interviewing controversial figures
because he's worried about worried about
offending people
you will drift into obscurity if you are
not willing to press the envelope and
say what needs to be said
well that's it for ethan i suppose
now look
i'm sure he'll be fine uh he's got a big
podcast still he's going to retain many
of his uh members but he's losing a lot
apparently at least that's what they're
saying that's he's losing sponsorship
saying that let me tell you man here at
tim cast irl
and timcast.com we have too many what
are you doing dan
is it gone
i i never
okay we got us we have a spec issue guys
stand by
[Music]
um
tim by the way i love this part dan go
tim goes actually we have too many
sponsors we have we have
lines of slot bucket people around the
corner
no for real you know we only do so many
sponsor spots every every month thank
you like between six and eight we've
increased a little bit and that's
because i tell our ad sales guys like i
don't want them
we've got we've got uh uh
today we are sponsored by gold for less
are you ready send in your grandma's old
gold jewelry
yeah
i still don't see it
it's there i've seen a few people in the
chat mention it now i just seen on
reddit and i was like all right all
right
we are taking care of the spec issue
we look in here on the spec spec gate
uh let's see
oh is it is it lens damage
no it's not lens damage it looks like
coffee or something
coffee oh my back oh maybe it is london
maybe it's inside the lens because it's
still there wait is it this here
yep oh [ __ ]
[Music]
looks like a stain on the tv
it's possible that's behind the lens
it's on the actual oh no how did that
happen take it off it's okay
we're just fine it's fun it's
interesting
all right we are taking the lens off
let's see what it looks like
[Music]
okay now we're gonna show dan taking the
lens off
this is this is real interesting stuff
guys
all right now wait show it i want to see
oh you're not supposed to let light in
[Music]
seriously i want to see what it looks
like
cut to it cut to it
oh it's white it's just white
not good for the sensor okay
well it's for science
so dan is trying to find the spec
uh there might be a speck on the sensor
maybe you see anything
okay we've got we've got air we're
squirting we're blasting
[Music]
interesting stuff
now i've got a i've got an experiment av
cover okay
now cut to it uh ian let's see if we can
see the spec
up
oh
okay i saw it for a second oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it was there and then it disappeared
yeah no i said oh
hey zach is eating beans
wait now i don't see it or i do see it
what is that it's bouncing around
i think it might be a glimp
wait it is a lens flare
yeah
[Music]
it's just one little dot
[Music]
and enjoy our zak enjoying beans let me
get some beans and tell us
so as we as dan tried you know
i i just want to once again apologize
to all the people of the globe who enjoy
beans and toast
oh this is nice so what what's this one
same
why are we doing with bushes
[Music]
cheerio
when you're hungry what better snack
than some beans on toast
mmm wait a minute my biggest coconuts
people of the world
my welsh people my irish people my
scottish people my englishman my
australians my canadians
hear me now
the beans on toast is the finest snack
it's also super healthy
what's better than
beans cooked in syrup on white bread
nothing
hmm
we also have a surprise today
wow
[Music]
you know i apologize
my scrumptious beans on toast
and then also we have another angle here
we we're bringing out vegemite
i have never tried vegemite
you know people in australia they've
messed with oh is that what it
i'm gonna let you is it on you do butter
and vegemite yeah you start with butter
wait what's the difference between
marmite and vegemite
[Music]
was it the same thing
so vegemite is yeast extract and my
goodness i've never heard of such a
thing
so i'm probably a lot of you have heard
about the vegemite phenomenon
it's a condiment that's used in um
australia
that apparently a lot of people find
repulsive
so while we're doing beans on toast
how's the spec gate going i see it still
wait how did you make it there it's gone
it's gone
that's such an interesting phenomenon
still there right as ever
can you just put like a bigger hood over
it
just tape a piece of paper or something
man
now butter
love butter
all right wow i didn't expect that i was
just black
that looks like a newborn baby [ __ ]
how many of you guys have seen
when you have a newborn baby
their first shits
for about three days
is jet black and tarry like this
yeah it's super weird nothing you'd ever
expect
smells nasty
porridge smell eh
yeast extract
from wheat and barley
so i'm expecting some kind of beer-ish
flavor
oh go ahead
like fermented kind of beer flavor
[Music]
so
here today to the australians
oh my god it's viscous it's thick as
hell dude
holy smokes
why is it so thick my goodness
all right well here you go
some fresh baby poo
shout out to my australian my dad to the
down under
[Music]
oh come on
it tastes like
inedible
tastes like chemical
it tastes like if you lick the bicycle
chain
[Music]
y'all can't be [ __ ] seriously eating
this [ __ ]
i think that's just proof that if you
grow up eating something you can get
used to anything because this tastes
like [ __ ] y'all
that's [ __ ] horrid y'all gotta try
this
and don't worry it's hard it's it's
it's allowed abc ain't got no excuse
this time
[Music]
yo what the hell
but you guys know it tastes like [ __ ]
right australians like come
apology on i'm out this definitely gonna
have to be apologizing yo what the wait
you said i put too much
i put too much
i did people say i put too much
how did i put too much i put so little
it's supposed to be a really thin layer
is that right
how much am i supposed to put on
very little bit okay
all right so let me thin it out
that's interesting wow
so let me ask you guys this if something
is so potent that if there's like one
solid drop you [ __ ] gag is that a
good food i don't know
like if you spread a drop of [ __ ] evenly
on a piece of bread you might not taste
it that much
how's that i spread it out as thin as
possible
super thin
[Music]
all right
this is how is it too much i spread it
out as much as possible
and there's butter on it guys there's
butter on it
okay here we go
[Music]
i don't that's fine i'm gonna take
another bite because
i'm not sure i tasted that much when you
spread out that thing
maybe that's the point
like caviar is just a
real tiny bit
i see what you guys ma'am
it's just supposed to be like a hint
yeah
is it better that way what do you think
well yeah it's better when something
tastes like [ __ ] when you taste it less
it tastes better
okay yeah that's
it's still horrible i'm sorry guys
like the minute i taste it you guys
gotta try it please
i need everyone to try i'll try it i'm
curious
here you can use my toast
yeah spread that
i don't
i'm sure they both taste like [ __ ]
what's the difference between marmite
and vegemite it's the same thing no
it's not according to a google search
okay let's do marmite
one one is savory and one is slightly
sweet i forget which one is well this
one must be sweet it's more syrupy
right i think the the british one is the
marmite is the one all right so i've got
now marmite with butter super thin i'm
scraping this thing for dear life okay
mama
[Music]
i'll be honest i don't really taste it
let me try again
maybe too little
you've gone too thin now
[Music]
people saying it's a different yeast
this one's not bad
i mean it's oh
no what happened you just sniff the
bottle it's better it's better but
that's like saying
i'd rather eat donkey [ __ ] than
horseshit
because their diet is more
fiber rich which one is which
oh just take are these all vegemite okay
all right i'm trying the vegemite i
swear to god y'all this is just proof
that you can eat grow up eating anything
dan went in for a bite he's chewing
considering
[Music]
i don't hate it
take a butt take
keep going
take one big bite there in the middle
yeah tell me about that
dan's crunching he's considering is that
the marmite who's the vegemite
oh the vegemite yeah yeah that's the one
i want you to
try everyone's kind of crunching away
because it's not bad really not bad i'm
kind of into it okay
[ __ ] me
i think mine had the proper amount it
seemed
like it was just a little little dab
just amy did you skip that did you lose
a lot of that one
i did oh come on dude
i'd rather discuss off air
oh
oh you got a reason for everything
okay
it's very salty
to me
in there and and it the savory it kind
of reminds me of um
[Music]
like miso
oh yeah yeah miso yeah which i'm not a
fan of see i like miso flavor a lot
there you go
all right well
apparently uh
i'm alone
i told you man
no cam cam's a hater
cam what's your review
i hate it i said it it's [ __ ]
disgusting i don't know how you can put
that in your mouth and have a positive
reaction yeah it's like eating sand i
mean it's like eating sand and being
like not bad
okay let me talk [ __ ] to the chat now
people are saying that i'm being a west
i'm being a baby guys it's ramadan i'm
not fasting but i don't want to eat
because i still look at it as being
disrespectful to my fellow muslims
brothers and sisters i didn't want to
say that but for the chat who's saying
that i'm just being a baby and staying
out that is why so blame them
with the regular [ __ ] you can say that
you can explain that i respect that yeah
and i know you are not fasting because
you're training right but you're being
respectful to your to the
but they're watching us eat they don't
you they don't need to see another yeah
i know muslim man eat right
well
my brother i like him salam and then i
would say that back alaikum salaam
peace be upon you peace be with you
peace
peace be upon you
it does seem like convenient though
oh we respect that certainly can't say
anything about it
a couple different companies
and i just say like not interested i i
don't want to deal with it that's fine i
want to make sure
tim he's just talking about how cool he
is that's like all he does i'm so cool i
get all these sponsors i have a
girlfriend shut up
who cares bro it's dumb ass
um
okay before we get to so ian you're
still in for the uh sumstro strowman you
know
it's up to you no pressure i've been
doing some bodily feeling out okay
there is a hundred percent chance i will
vomit if i can eat that fish
i'm not feeling good today
okay that
just that will happen
that will happen doesn't that so so
how does that affect your choice
wait you still want me to i will i will
doesn't affect me i don't care if you
puke right next to you
you're going to run to me and puke here
no well i'm going to come over next to
you in front of you sure no if you eat
in front of me i'm fine that's what i'm
saying you guys all worried about the
smell come sit in front of the smell of
the whole building i know but it's worse
if i'm sitting in front of it i mean
certainly it's worse if you're listening
it's your choice man i'm not i you know
[Music]
don't do it ian
your choice don't do it uh i'll leave it
i'll let sam decide
um i have a hundred dollars on you got a
handy tim oh come on
bro
sam changed her tune real fast for that
hundy she didn't have to do [ __ ] except
smell your ass well she has to smell it
for the next several days and she she
gave it the green like does he have to
walk or will you give him a ride
hmm you got to give him a ride
that's what the hundreds for hmm all
right
i'll throw i'll throw in a ride
do i have to get the tail and the whole
thing like last time
yes
what
[ __ ] i'll tell you what the little the
two little fins at the end you don't
have to eat
uh
it's up to you bro i'm not no pressure
one way or the other i'll be happy if
you don't because i don't have to pay
you guys 600 bucks i've seen a lot of
do-its and but but if you do it's good
entertainment
i'll do it i'll do it oh wow oh my
goodness gracious this is happening god
this is chad's fault
this is what your membership money goes
to my friends okay this is the bell
curve yeah i was talking about it i
didn't realize but he actually has a lot
of good experience
uh this is interesting so he says i'm
lower on the bell curve right so you're
like kind of near his ear level oh
normal shape dome
like temple ear level whereas he's
clearly
well he's at the air too but on the
opposite side he's he's you know in the
upper echelon okay so this makes more
sense when i know what he's talking
about yeah i didn't know he was a cone
head huh yeah he's at the top of the
bell curve right or no he's at the mile
that's right he's on the right side of
the bell curve is the thing
i i'm [ __ ] dying over this
might be the best photoshop from camera
actually can you guys tweet this out
right now because this is actually like
i feel like this is a twitter this could
become a twitter staple
thanks so much uh let's do let's tweet
this out and just say temple says i'm
i'm on the on the back end of the bell
curve what do you guys think
yeah that's a good tweet we need this we
need are you working on that logo
actually why don't i tweet it
here send me the image i'll tweet it for
my own
i'll send it i'm gonna drop a banger out
there
i'm so proud now that i was like i was
like wait did you guys find that on the
internet what cam made that holy [ __ ]
that's awesome
too it's me
man's a me machine
what can you say
all right
[Music]
did it get shrunk no okay so guys head
on over to twitter
where we can ratio temple
so the caption is gonna be
i'm gonna cut the sides off a little bit
cam because on twitter
you don't want it to be too wide
you do you
just no disrespect here to your work
so let's see uh tim
timpool
said i'm on
[Music]
i'm on the back
what do you say back end of the balcony
back side of the bell curve or some show
like the back side
of the bell curve
[Music]
where do you guys think
he is on it
so tim timple said i'm on the back
side of the bell curve where do you guys
think he is on it
there you go
camily camily show support guys this is
an important one
family family
family
i love that vin diesel left
yo with with god's grace god willing i'm
pretty sure
that we're going to be seeing this meme
in a lot of his replies
one can only hope
that's the power of the public square
yeah this is really good this is really
good information
like in terms of charting and stuff yeah
so there you have it
it's time to flex those cam just earned
his salary for the year muscles
hell yeah
oh all right
ian why don't you join me
come see the finale are we done
no let's keep talking about stuff as it
takes a minute i want to talk about the
lebron family
uh
because i think
i think we're all going to want to get
the [ __ ] out of here pretty quickly
after ian all right like it should be
like the last thing we do
i'm not going to want to stay in this
room
i think you're forgetting just like how
intense i'm not and i'm glad to sit here
to prove to you guys that i'm willing to
to take us you all want to get paid i'm
going to sit here and i'm going to take
it right in the face okay so you guys
can't complain that i've got no skin in
the game okay all right i guess that's
that is fair so i want to talk about the
lebran family before this you know the
little brant family
they're like this christian family and
it turns out they're the worst people in
the world of course they always are
and um
for being a family channel right not for
being christian well they like are like
we're great saintly christians but
they're actually
exp
exploiting their kids right
saying that kids have cancer for views
when they don't yes
and now we got a really disturbing
insight
into their analytics
um
by the way
did you guys figure out how she got
access to these analytics
i don't believe we did
because
that was a question i had about all this
but apparently
the nine-year-old daughter
has her own instagram page
oh it's instagram so is there a way to
see ant demographic information on
there's like a social you can use like
social blade
for instagram but how could you see
demographic information
this is disgusting though this is a good
christian family that clickbaits their
kids having cancer i didn't even know
this their nine-year-old daughter has an
interest oh she's verified yeah how's
that feel ian
well she has 5 million followers so
don't feel too bad i guess it's true
i love to dance and have fun with my
family ran by my mom
i'm sorry but this is [ __ ] horrific a
nine-year-old with an instagram page
with five million
and so the really and so well okay it's
just a kid right what's wrong with that
um
well
your work spheres are about to be
confirmed and this is where 400 000
likes
genuinely
oh my so let me just read this
and whatever people saying like i
thought you had to be 13 to have an
instagram account i guess if the mom is
the one running it that's like a way
around that i feel like that should not
it's creepy yeah and let me show you why
okay
so this lady got the analytics from one
way or another
uh
here i'm gonna use this comment as an
opportunity to show you this clip from
the dad challenge podcast over on his
youtube video discussing the analytics
of everleigh labrador did you guys
review the source
video
nobody watched the podcast that that
clip's from
i'm not sure we did this right up
oh we we dug for it we honestly we
couldn't find the clip you couldn't find
the podcast no we couldn't find it on
his channel
the dad challenge podcast
the specific clip he was talking about
we couldn't find it okay
the debt okay i believe you
so this is just like some rando on tick
tock saying this that's what we need to
get that's why we need to find the
source i need to know
well she she was putting showing a clip
from she said she said to clarify these
analytics are from instagram not youtube
but how do we get the analytics we need
to know that this is genuine
well anyway here's what she says
the largest child creators on social
media and please note these analytics
are from a year ago
so
they might be a little out to date but
it expresses
can you go on our tech talk and see if
she explained because i'm sure pretty
sure a lot of people are wondering how
she got it
for christ's sake you guys
i'm about to have a uh
what was it diva moment is that where
you're going no there was someone who
got in trouble for yelling at people
what was it oh gordon ramsay we're
talking about
not actually angry but knob head
it would be nice to get a little more
depth on this exactly this point
good demographics everybody
70 male
lowest percentage is teenagers so where
is he he's on the influencer profile so
he's on
some kind of back end
i mean there are a lot of third-party uh
things that you know try and analyze the
analytics uh
just through api and stuff like that but
yeah i mean as you know like socialblade
is in 100 accurate i'm sure this isn't
either but it's gonna be in the ballpark
because i wonder if through the facebook
advertising platform you can see the
breakdown of certain pages so you know
if you want to like respond
i don't know
i know i don't know but anyway so so
anyway let's just assume for the sake of
uh understanding that that this is real
although there's some possibility that
we don't know where the analytics came
from lowest percentage is teenagers so
we can just eliminate that but here we
go 24 everybody
70 male
lowest percentage is teenagers so we can
just eliminate that but here we go 24 19
that's 50 of their male audience of 70
percent
is watching this little girl and is
between the ages of 18 and 44. that is
so [ __ ] disgusting what is 70 of 5.2
million 70 of 5.2 million is 3.64
million
this is why this conversation matters
yeah so
so let's just assume it's it's real for
the sake of uh
the conversation
um
five million followers
seventy percent are male
ages 18 to 50.
that is horrifically disgusting
is that creepy or what
and then this is this good christian mom
who's throwing her kids to the sharks
she manages it she knows the analytics
they're obviously doing it for business
purposes
and she can see that
there's creepy old pedos watching her
daughter
i mean most people without they would be
disgusted by that but they don't mind
because they click bait
their kids having cancer so who gives a
[ __ ] if there's millions of pedos
watching her daughter on
yikes on instagram
yeah they need to they need to clamp
down on the
kids on social media and youtube thing
it's just
like we as a society decided a long time
ago that you know kids in entertainment
need protection and
this weird loophole that all these
people are able to just kind of avoid
any of that
needs to be closed well the problem is
this none of these kids have grown up
yet and being like yo my parents abused
me
my parents never paid me yeah you're
right in a decade my parents took me out
of school and forced me to work
[Music]
look at this happy christian family yeah
wait till we get the stories about your
kids in [ __ ] 20 years
but we all know look there's about that
ryan toy review documentary is going to
be [ __ ] crazy
as for me and my household we will serve
the lord um yeah we're also going to
serve a bunch of pedos on instagram
so what is that what joshua meant
you [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
scum
i tell you what man
i have nothing but disdain for religious
people who are just dog [ __ ] people it's
like they use their christianity as a
shield
or whatever religion they are they use
it as a it's it's mostly christians
though who
do this because they can
just they think as long as they're good
with jesus as long as they accept jesus
as their savior you could do literally
any crime
and be good and death right that's how
it works
[ __ ] that
i'm not down with that [ __ ] sort of sort
of that word yeah no that's not sort of
you ask g if you accept jesus in your
heart you're good
i mean
you have it's it's not i mean you have
to genuinely uh
okay hold on feel remorse and uh be
asking us okay but fine yeah like you
can't just be like on the deathbed
oh yeah i'm sorry about all that yeah
she's like no no i'm really sorry for
real yeah theoretically that would that
would not uh get you into heaven
flame flare
okay zach abe found the quote
i guess i was looking in the wrong place
i apologize
maybe comment
you just muted
my mic program is restarting but in
zack's defense there was a ton of videos
from him on this subject uh-huh but you
just found it in like 10 minutes well
i'm the goat
oh
okay he's the go so michael jordan of
googling
from the cell using if you use okay look
family vloggers [ __ ] selling mlms
[ __ ] but if you use your faith to
make money
you're just as bad as uh these pastors
who do it so i'm with you buddy coming
right after you by the way this is the
dad channel podcast girl is
inappropriate splits dancing bunny ears
just gross now look at her demographics
everybody
70
mail so let me go back and see if he
mentions the analytics he's using
oh so he's using a third party
yeah that's what i figured
yeah i mean those those will be in the
ballpark like it's probably not far off
from this yeah
[ __ ] bro
there you have it
now in zack's defense av it is your job
to go over the document and make sure
all the info's there just to say just to
alleviate him from a little bit
is that [ __ ] still crashed yeah there
you go
uh yeah my thing's not working yeah uh i
apologize
[Music]
alrighty
i'm trying here it's me and zach we
don't have olivia
so anyway uh
that's that all right ian come let's eat
some [ __ ] oh god
you can still back out by the way
maybe you should
it's up to you maybe you should
man that's really disturbing though that
kind of blew my mind like i knew the
lebran family was disgusting pieces of
[ __ ] but the fact that they know what
the analytics is i didn't even know
their nine-year-old had an instagram
account but knowing
that it's seventy percent men
following her nine-year-old daughter
makes me wanna [ __ ] die
by the way a b and uh and zach you're
forgiven
you're both incredible employees i'm
very lucky to have you
thank you thank you
my mic's still not working zach yeah i
said thank you okay i just want to point
out abe can't even get to his mic
towards yeah he can't even get his mic
working doesn't even know how to work a
microphone that's good sorry who's the
audio guy who's there you unplugged your
[ __ ] dude wait wait wait wait wait wait
everything's the audio guy zach that's
true i am i can't help once the mic is
in front of him which by the way he
doesn't even talk into
why did what what did you mumble
well
he he he i can what say something i'll
repeat it
so do i need to do everything for him do
i need to walk through this so so
like you're doing dance said do i need
to do everything for you zack
check check
it's not working
[Music]
it's out
thank you dan
i was muted
yeah
it's true you are the audio guy zack
you should have jumped out of your chair
to fix it
it's not that easy to just get up
all right unfortunately ian you have a
there's a big margin here that wants to
see you eat that fish bro i i i threw
that up while they were fixing hoping
the audience would would bail me out
here no they're not bailing you out man
giving the audience too much power they
can do it they can still bail you out
guys
what if he doesn't want to eat it do
another poll i don't think he wants to
eat it i feel like he feels obligated to
eat it
yeah don't do it mom uh it's not worth
it love how you feeling from me i'm
feeling um
actually physically i'm fine like
totally fine now everything's my
microphone smells i've i'm gonna have to
change it like
do something about that i'm like takes
my um at my clothes that [ __ ] smells i'm
[ __ ]
it'll go well it will yeah it'll
or you'll get used to it one or the
other well i'll have to change the mic
cover which isn't that bad but i'll just
have to clean this yeah you know garbage
men and like
you know uh waste processing facility
workers and stuff they they say
they can't smell the smell you can't
smell anything yeah so you know in a day
or two in like 10 minutes you'll get
used to it and then it's just when a
friend comes over or a date maybe they'd
be like i'm leaving
i went to the bathroom earlier and uh
immediately as i came upstairs outside
even my dad's bedroom is outside here i
just [ __ ]
smelled this
did your dad say anything yet no my dad
is sleeping so i'm hoping he doesn't
think he's gonna wake up
he won't be able to fall asleep again
because it's not bad it smells down to
the first level and ever
i put everything that touched the fish
outside and i'll deal with it uh
tomorrow
all right let's redo the poll and
it doesn't bind you
okay you can still do whatever you want
but let's see people of the world will
you save ian
so we're just i will all right whatever
this one says i'll do it no questions
asked there you go but so what do you
want them to vote for you want them to
vote no i'm not going to sway this is it
you've pretty much said you don't want
you don't you don't want to do it you
said you were hoping they would vote no
people it's in your hands
will ian eat the fish
will he not
the pole decides now
has he swayed
the public with his pleas for help
he says please don't make me do this
audience
still waiting for the response here and
now it is on you
our beautiful loyal fans
to decide
still showing me uh zero the paul is
currently lagging yeah it'll be it'll
catch up
it'll get there it's broken there's just
a lot of people voting i think just
saying uh i told ian he has to take me
out to dinner if he does it just say so
uh
you what you're gonna wanna go out to
dinner with him smell him like that you
can't manipulate the polls
i would no i was just just adding you
just checked out the information
the polls like busted it you're trying
to stay inside
you're just trying to sweeten the deal
right sam
yeah exactly
sam
wait it just wasn't showing i got the
results though
what is it
five thousand seven hundred votes
fifty one to forty eight no
no actually one well do it again because
i don't believe you i i mean it's a bat
it's a rigged pull just do it again it's
a red
okay
if you want the hundred bucks you have
to give him a peck afterwards
you can't add stuff now i've changed the
terms pray i don't change them more no
you just a pack you know that's you know
no you can't you can't add things now
it's too late these are this is my show
i'll do as i please damn it all right i
put up the new poll wow
i have to say our audience is so caring
how i i can't believe that you guys are
actually voting though god bless them
i don't i'm truly shocked
that there's enough people here that
would vote no i think our shit's bugged
out it's doing it again it just says
zero votes i'm telling you though i mean
here's love shared the screenshot here
i'll put it up on the screen yeah that's
6 000 votes that's quite a lot yeah i
mean
that's so close though
i feel like i feel like if people could
see the voting
it would affect the voting well you
can't you can't see before you vote
maybe this is better it's like anonymous
is so that you know all right everybody
this one this is the one that counts get
it in
y'all really voting no on this huh
they're basically saying no we want the
show to end we don't want more show
oh my god
[Music]
what's happening now
that's just like totally like
okay vote yes so the show doesn't end
i'm not listen people it's their power
their power to do what they want what's
it at now dan i i literally can't see
until you end it until i end it and then
it shows the results so all right well
what do you think should i end it
i call them listen everybody's voted by
now i'm assuming so go ahead dan
end the poll and put the results on the
screen here we go here we go
okay i see it in the chat yeah you see
it
should ian eat the fish so this one says
53
yes
with even more votes 7.6 000 votes on
this one
thoughts
do you want another one ian
is the point there's a little rigged
i've got to say how is it rigged they're
stealing this one had 2 000 more votes
dumps do you not want to do it okay how
about this
you want to rig it so bad
i'll do it but you need to take a little
bite no
just a little i didn't rig [ __ ] i was
just surprised
dude how often do you see interesting
how often do you see you don't want to
you don't want the showdown i'll take a
bite and i'm not and how about i take a
bite and i don't pay you anything
how about that
well then this then become a game of
poker
i'll take a little bite and i don't pay
you [ __ ] how about that exactly
zach wants you to throw in a rolex not
gonna happen a rolex
sit down okay let's just get this over
with
i'm done all right
all right
all right here it is so the people have
spoken
listen i was just i was expressing my
sincere
shock that we have such a
a benevolent audience like i is there
any other audience in the world that
would just not vote 100 yes eat the
[ __ ] fish
you know what i mean
i mean it is shocking
god speed ian godspeed people want me to
eat it nobody's paying me damn
who's going to pay me to eat it
why would i eat it
[Music]
how much you're going to pay me to eat
dude that thing looks like
it's it's bursting look at how look at
that wait is it supposed to be doing
that
that's what a mine didn't do that's why
it's square yeah that's that's how it is
it's like it's bulging
see that's why you why you want a
plastic bag i see
holy [ __ ]
yo if okay somebody
open that [ __ ] on camera should ethan
eat the fish well of course you're gonna
say yes but who the [ __ ] paying me
i'm about to drop six hundred dollars
for these people 700 for love
93 yes
well
i'm very happy that you all think i
should eat it but
i'm going to scoot it over
actually what if we do a subathon and
i'll eat this thing
a subathon
a member of dawn i don't know how many
members would be worth it i have kids
damn it ow my back i'm all the only one
here that has kids
hold on i gotta pee let me think about
this i'll be right back my phone doesn't
necessarily need you there that's pretty
cool this is close you can do it right
here i don't care there's no mic on that
side it's hard for me to do oh there's
there's no camera here
because it's just uncomfortable to talk
to when you're next to me open to write
my face i don't care
yeah all right i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna go pee i'll be right back okay and
then ian why don't you just talk through
maybe you guys could think of
a condition
for me to take a bite
how about the audience
votes 92 that you should take a bite
yeah that seems pretty it's pretty good
condition
no
all right we got to get to three million
subs
oh that's interesting
he said three million subs right now
he'll eat it
[Music]
seems fair do it sign up zach help me
out here buddy
you want ethan to eat the fika fish and
you want to see some grotesque some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] we need to get you to
this channel to 3 million subscribers so
hit that subscribe button hit that bell
and can i get a whoop
[Music]
subscribe
that subbathon idea is pretty cool
though because we could take like shifts
streaming if that makes sense and we
have a continuous stream
until the stop member remembering there
we go
you heard it here
i can take the night shift
[Music]
oh true
24 hour
interesting and we never stop until yeah
whatever
pretty fun
we've been going what like three hours
yeah exactly three hours ian's asking me
what we should do with the camera uh
yeah um that's why
i thought you guys should sit next to
each other but
that was vetoed i can move the mic
[Music]
are you the audio guy the camera stuff
[Music]
here ian come back over here
[Music]
yeah
ian's going to take back over i'm going
to go set up another camera
hi how's everyone's day going today i
hope at a
fantastic what's that
oh yeah
zach lewis live with them in april 30th
this saturday night link in my instagram
bio it's going to be amazing time i'm
going to play with my band gonna be a
good old time gonna play some original
tunes some covers
it's gonna be fun here here
ian can you switch to me
can you hear me
yes i can [ __ ] hear you
[Music]
i'm on the y i'm on the wide
oh
but yeah this saturday night zach lewis
live at the minute link in my instagram
bio and twitter
i can't wait to go cam's gonna be
there i'll be there all of us are going
to be there yeah it's going to be a good
old time
you know i bought a ticket and didn't
refund it sack
i bought a ticket and didn't refund it
for the original show oh that's very
sweety i can send you the money back
no it's for you appreciate that love
a good guy
i can hear ethan
washing his hands
and unfortunately we did not hit
three million
it's a bummer man
wait are you seeing that on back end
because
i'm nothing
i got a double check
yeah you got to get the live updates
here zeko is live at the mint
[Music]
um i mean we did gain 5 000 subs i think
that's pretty good
actually no
we did again a couple
uh
yep we just did it congratulations
everyone
i made it
back yeah there you go three million
subs awesome and i'll take a bite it
ain't yeah we're there we're there we
hit it wait
what about
setting out a goal for next week because
a lot of people watching might subscribe
then
that's a good point um
so you're saying bye monday
yeah but people are just gonna be weird
and like make fake accounts and [ __ ]
i mean love specifically
i have a funny meme i'm going to eat
chocolate as he eats
the sum stressing where did him go
what kind of chocolate is that
i don't know why does it look so fancy
it just tastes like normal chocolate the
golden one is that swedish we have
exactly no it's called
comparatives
i don't think so
all right dean how are you feeling
not good
funny you can back out at any time
the election was stolen from me
hey we okay so he's
well could
all right is everyone ready wait get the
shot get the shot i get it and shot
uh can somebody man the camera because
this isn't we don't want to miss this i
mean it's a big deal now
oh i should do it in the back for me
what okay you don't have to do it in the
bag i want to know i want to use i'm
going to take it
for the initial so here put the mic up
to it maybe so we can hear if it makes
like a loud yeah
oh yeah you hear that you picking that
up oh yeah we are decay right there my
friend
yeah it's it's splashing
it's splashing on the bag oh god that
initial spray is dangerous dude dude the
bubble noise you said you just didn't
spray huh love or did
it it didn't spray that much because i
had it on a 45 degree angle now ian will
you smell your fingers real fast i feel
like the finger test is really
interesting
no i'm smelling it
i don't need to smell my fingers no i
don't i don't smell it yet personally
but um
really sam's already covering no i don't
smell it yet that bag is really
concealing it
here smell my fingers
i'm good
by the way this is extra aged
oh there comes that's kind of what the
term is the quality of the fish how long
it's been aged the more the better
and you're not supposed to refrigerate
it to a certain extent
so at a certain extent it's aged too
much
the fingers are going to be [ __ ] right
right
your fingers okay what happened your
fingers no because i had to open the lid
give yours give your fingers one more
smell for the people at home just get a
good shot of get a big old whiff
yeah i'll smell it it's fine you're
right so let me just show the people
what it actually looks like chocolate
milk like cocoa a little bit you should
dunk your chocolate in there
dude
no no come on i can't how am i supposed
to angle you can see speak a foul
come on how's it ever going to come out
of the carpet damn
yeah so it's gonna get a good smell i
mean i got the liquid on my finger bro
that's okay not on your fingers
[Music]
dude i've never spotted anything worse
in my whole life
i swear to god
like if you just dipping your finger in
there and smelling it it's unfucking
believable
oh my god
does anyone else want to come smell it
nope i'll give it a whiff no come here
zach no but like smelling the fumes
is nothing compared to like smelling the
juice
do me a favor zach dip your finger in
and just smell your finger god get a
good dunk holy [ __ ] here sit down here
just dip your finger in and smell the
tip taste your finger no no you don't
have this i'm not sticking my [ __ ]
finger
dude here smell my fingers got the [ __ ]
out of it please i just it makes such a
big difference do not put that i'm not
gonna move it i'm not gonna move it i
swear
it's unbelievable oh no
don't don't puke on camera
dude
that's [ __ ] bad man
let me get another whiff
you gotta put it right on your nose it's
unbelievable right
it's like the worst i can't show him
oh my god
will you smell my finger maybe come on
you wouldn't you owe it to us the smell
get right in there i don't trust you i'm
not gonna move it
it's crazy right
it's like it's like leaving he's leaving
the room
the fumes is bad but once you actually
smell it up close it's shocking it is it
is far worse than life
it's like next level right yeah it's
like now the fact that i don't know how
you're i gotta wash my hands real fast
just up here
holy [ __ ] dude it's the finger of death
oh no
you know what this does not give me any
pleasure
the hor the horrible thing
the horrible thing about this the the
fish there's so much fish
it's like bubbling up and out
it's like gurgling yeah they look
bloated like alive i gotta ask you guys
buddy wait hold on cut to me
cam's going to smell my finger oh it's
over here oh there it is i've been
waiting it just it just hit us over here
wait dan where where was this anyone
else sam lina
sam come on lena i'd like to get your
reaction if possible sam's coming
no it's different here i'm gonna get
i'll get a dump for you okay oh my god
don't make lena do it
no
oh my god
sam oh i've never had so many people
smell my fingers before
that is a whole different ball game man
watch
yeah
yeah
it's different right i don't i mean tip
of the beanie
dan where was i i got to watch mine
where was this for all this time oh we
had it in the pantry
the pay was in the pantry it was then
the one downstairs we forgot to bring it
back up here i hated how quickly dan
knew where it was yeah dan what was that
about how did you know where it was well
that's where we stored it
i just remembered that after we had an
extra one and i we threw it in the
pantry and then when we moved studios we
didn't bring it over so it was so bad i
smelt it i coughed and i farted
like all at once yeah
i coughed so hard that i farted
but you can't even smell my fart because
the mess by this yeah
this is like some
oh my god dude this is like some
jigsaw's
nightmare puzzle
like i gotta dig my fingers in here to
get a key out it's crazy it's hard to
describe okay that's definitely
respectable so basically just eat up to
where your fingers are you don't have to
hold the tail oh just you just need to
wait
you said you didn't want to eat okay i
want to take a look at it hold on wait
wait this so
i can't believe you're doing this man
you encourage me if i'm you can't
believe it huh
you can't believe it
with the ballot box
you could have said no at any time
i guess it's true
yo i washed my hands really good
and it still smells like it's like farts
bro
okay so show i think show they'll pulled
it up so you could kind of see the flesh
and stuff
you can get a close-up of that if you
can zoom in more maybe
so yeah you can kind of just see it's
fleshy
you can still back out you can still
back out
you can still back out ian you don't
have to do this
whoever has to use this mic next
apologies this thing is going to be
stinking
all right i guess i'll do the cartoon
tomcat
you don't have to do it i'm just saying
okay all right
oh my god
oh my god
how's it taste does it taste like it
smells
holy [ __ ] he's quivering
he's not chewing he just
so this is what he did last time you
have to kind of transcend
a mind and body
right now he's transcending mind and
body
he's chewing i he's chewing he's nodding
no
he's nodding no i'm feeling a little
nauseous
i'm feeling a little not he's shaking
i'm feeling a little nauseous oh no oh
no oh no
he's chewing now he's chewing
it is
[Music]
the bones i can't deal with the guts
[Music]
ian thoughts
[Laughter]
someone come take the can away please
well show the bones show evie i want to
show the bones
go to the bathroom for christ's sake man
he's like in the corner of her
baby just yeah i got close when i saw
you pulling the bones out of your mouth
did he actually throw up
i think he did yeah
i don't know how god i don't know how
you do that
show the bones off
he pulled the spine there's another
piece
how do you do that man
so can you talk so when you were there
with your eyes closed not chewing what
were you thinking about
well
um my hands are so juiced
um
you just um
well you can feel the whole
nervous system
the spine and the bones
[Music]
and does it taste like it smells
damn
you'll find out when we hit 3 million
now i'm just if that i'm just
first of all i didn't uh
i said a little nibble guys
ah thank you kim
oh
somebody just donated a hundred bucks
said can we add this to his prize
oh my god you guys
thank you that's very cool this guy said
can we add this to the prize it's very
sweet all right we did it and we got a
bunch more left you know wait how you
got how are you going to preserve that
put in some tupperware put it in the
fridge
yeah yeah i'll be into my cat later
he'll probably know
okay
y'all are you still oh that's gum okay
but i want to talk that through like
you put it in your mouth and there's a
point where
yeah okay thanks get the spine up close
there you go
i mean it's close enough but okay
so like when you get real close it has a
special smell is that kind of what the
flavor is
it's like
it's it like rocks through your through
your whole nose it's like doing it um
what is it
oh a salt okay uh nothing salt yeah like
a smelling salt
um
so it's like eating a skeleton smelling
salt experience
you seem fine i just don't know how you
do that did you think you were gonna
have to bail at some point or did you
know you were gonna get it done i knew
well it's just the the bones you feel
them all poking around and okay and it's
really weird and uncomfortable but you
knew you would get it i could slam that
fish
i think you're one of the only few in
the world i'll be honest apparently the
swedes love it except love they don't
eat it like that no no we don't need
this like that it's like buried in it
it's bubbling it's like so fermented and
rotting it's literally bubbling yeah
it's got a good
could uh
would you do another one for another
five minutes stop it would you you
should you're already here it's open
you're making me make me broke
no no more fish
no more i have to draw the line
so you're welcome everyone well
congratulations ian thank you
you seemed fine had somebody take the
fish away for granted all right i guess
i'm just gonna leave good i can't i
gotta get away from this dude the whole
[ __ ] uh building smells
i got bad news guys
only the two small windows along the
side open
the big ones at the back
oh my god oh dude i've been breathing
through my mouth but like
what about just a lick of fish zach just
lick a fish
how much
uh
200
lick the fish for 200 yeah
whoa i don't think
how much of a lick are we talking about
from top to bottom
a whole tongue not just the tip whole
tongue all right
do
100.
every time we bring out this zomstross
and i go broke
it's all for you guys okay oh my [ __ ]
god
i'm not i there's nothing in it for me
okay if somebody's putting up money we
can talk
and people are going oh ethan you got to
do it
which one of these guys is doing it for
free nobody's doing it for free oh jesus
[ __ ]
like i said i don't have sponsors on
this episode oh
all right so so oh my god hold that up
so they can see what is that the guts is
just coming is it just dripping all over
the table we're gonna need a new table
no there's plastic down okay and there's
plastic yeah there's plastic on the
floor oh my goodness okay so what i want
you to do
is put the intestines or whatever that
is coming out and just suck on it this
has got to be like 300 no it's a hundred
just to suck just suck the juice off it
you don't have to eat anything
you got it's got to be like hold on hold
on before you get in there we said it's
got to be a real bad lick from talk to
me whole tongue though not just the tip
you have to really commit
what are you doing you're not i'm
licking it you didn't what how do you
want me to be sexy i'm not trying to how
do you want me to lick it
you gotta just suck that and spit it out
this yeah put it all in your mouth hold
it up show that what is that
what is that
that's the part i swallowed oh you
actually swallowed some love
yeah i got a piece in my mouth and i
just [ __ ] dude you don't have to
swallow it that's what that's why i
puked you don't have to swallow it
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was
that was something
[Music]
i mean compared to what ian did i can't
even
was that enough av was that warranted
what'd you think abe is giving the knot
of approval okay yeah i mean you tasted
it you tasted it
you received about 200 extra in
donations at this point
people are saying that wasn't enough
actually
i saw one comment say it at least
yes
what do you mean if it wasn't enough
why are we just i'm just sitting there
i keep burping so what maybe it wasn't
that bad if you're willing to come back
how are you i got a big weekend
just put it all in close your mouth and
then spit it out i i can't you can't
okay you're good i'll give you a hundred
get out of here
it's like
oh sam says i stink
everybody i didn't want this i don't you
think i want to spend a thousand dollars
on you clowns to eat some fish there's
people starving around the world who'd
be would be overjoyed to be eating fish
i'm just the one sitting in front of the
can you can barely smell it over there
dude it was like a minute later and like
oh i could smell it now it's right in
front of me you're suffering i'm
suffering more than you
okay and don't be saying ethan do it
what's in it for me
exactly
ian smells so [ __ ]
ian
bad
a [ __ ] god among men by the way
no
i can't believe you put that thing down
ian that don't use my microphone
get away from my microphone
yeah he's in discord what's in it for me
what are you guys talking to me about it
i'm not doing [ __ ] with that fish dude
like it tastes like
just like
poseidon's taint it is the back of my
throat it's it smells like [ __ ] but
that doesn't do it justice you know what
i mean
it's so much worse
yeah aqua [ __ ] i think is good
sam's not the victim she got 100 bones
out of it too
everyone's happy ian got about four or
five hundred dollars in donations
yeah she pushed the poll
excuse me you were don't try tonight now
we we we redid that poll though
[Music]
there was a
all right guys we got enough fika fish
for dinner tonight so
you guys are champions though enjoy it
thank you guys
for watching
people are saying we pay you ethan we
are your members
it's true no sponsors today
dude
he's looking at the can
he just looked over at it what do we
what about 3 million by the next podcast
how many subs we have right now 2.97
oh yeah that's way off it didn't even
move
three mill by the next pod
but we don't even have another can to
open we're not going to sit let this sit
open we'll figure it out
i just can't see it i what do you guys
what are you doing for me
i can't see it guys you keep saying that
these members
the people in the chat so what i'm
supposed to just dance monkey dance
anytime these people want oh yeah i do a
whole damn show i feel like there's an
equal exchange you're here for okay
you'll really think i'm gonna eat a
whole one at most i'm gonna lick one
like what zach did
i'm not eating it that's reasonable
look at that [ __ ]
okay if i lick it all deaths are
absolved
wait to them
i can't all deaths are absolved what the
[ __ ] oh no i can't i can't exactly see
that's not my money to give away exactly
so we said do it with a son hassan did
this too he ate it or he just smelled it
i think he ate it right pull up that
clip
i want to see if you actually can go i
can't take this smelly no it's so bad
it's it's weirdly like christmassy it's
like christmas from home
do you smell that kind of christmasy
smell no i just smell rotting fish that
doesn't remind me of christmas
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] called strum
wet strawberry
sushrami stew strom man
someone says kiss it i'll kiss it
kiss it
yeah you want to pay me
what's wrong with kissing it
was it this stream with ludwig and uh
misc yeah i want to see if hassan
actually ate it i'm not sure
they're in the backyard
actually i just want to know if any of
these guys actually ate it because i'm
so impressed by what ian did i don't
think anyone else could do that
this kid does what the [ __ ] going on
that's a little piece what is that
little piece
yeah you probably just want to eat a
little part off it
yo look at this give his arms wait why
he's eating the bones
i think it's just what he pulled out of
the can so it's not that bad he ate the
bones
good even
definitely not i mean that's impressive
definitely impressive
is he about to yakk
who else ate money
if you're gonna brush the bones in my
mouth
why did he eat the bones that was in our
lives
and they all and ludwig also ate
wait here's if if it's on it it's right
here
dude what what do you want i can't hold
this phone
here grab there's two paper towels
everywhere
hey does he go for it
he drains it
i think he's gonna go he's picking
around he's full center you have a nice
little strand just a little what the
[ __ ] why is he looks like hair you
finding a drink the thing
is mischief ate a little piece i still
think what ian did is the next level
yeah yeah to eat a whole just the whole
damn thing
yeah that's just a little speck and i'm
not willing to do that but and it's
impressive don't get me wrong
there it goes all right well there you
go
he's done more than you ethan
all right well he did it
that counts it's not as impressive what
he ended but he did it so there you go
i wonder if there's anyone in the world
that could do what he did i really
genuinely do because you have to chew on
it you know what i mean you like he
chews and chews and chews it's just so
impressive
ethan you got to take a bite what what
what do you cut you can't even give it
to 3 million hassan did
can't leave any
[Music]
leftovers all right get me like a fork
or something so
[Applause]
bro you guys
you guys there's a little taste of your
own medicine okay
no but listen nobody's paying me i i
just paid out like a thousand dollars
for people of the h3 nation pay you
yeah
like the monkey you are
okay guys i'm gonna lick this okay
and
and when i lick
just remember that i've done this here
for you guys today
and i don't want to anyone else
they here call me david dober because
david dobrik would never [ __ ] do this
he would never lick the face david what
nothing
said he was gonna start chanting david
don't you [ __ ] dare i'm not gonna do
it
okay and then become a member
watch our [ __ ] show
no complaining ever again
go to teddy fresh
buy something go to raptrading.com
and get some that doesn't help trading
cards
only a few days left on the pre-order by
the way only a few days left
i started breaking my notes for a second
and dude i got nauseous again
okay
all right you [ __ ] p you [ __ ]
this isn't my apology to all of our
lgbtq plus webers to all the brits
australians irish scottish all beans and
toast enthusiasts around the world
this is to tim poole who would it was a
coward who wouldn't do this this is what
it looks like inside your slot bucket
temple you don't have the balls to
[ __ ]
who's that going to apologize today oh
realtors realtors this is to realtors
everywhere oh my god it's so squishier
than you would expect a valuable service
to society realtors thank you and now
just let it be known that
it's so it's actually so soft like it's
not
yeah it's like a tender cooked slow
cooked beef yeah
it's just really soft through like you
could easily just keep thinking that put
in your mouth and swallowing i'm not
[ __ ] eating [ __ ] zach i said i'd lick
it
[Music]
don't be coming asking me for a rolex
you all put me up to this [ __ ] i didn't
want that you think i wanted to pay a
thousand dollars
trust me
times are hard man you got sponsors
leaving
all right
[Music]
there's a good chance i'm gonna puke
guys all right be ready to cut away and
have the finger on the trigger there i'm
gonna try to do a big look for the
family just right up so here right up
the side baby
right up the gills i'm just going to do
a big lick
up the whole side okay
is that good one happy with that yeah
and keep that swedish bigger bigger than
zach's in fact here's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna hold the tail so it's taut
i'm gonna hold the okay
because when i'm looking it's not that
camera wait can you what's my camera
when it's on your right side which
camera am i on because i'm seeing myself
on the preview and i'm not seeing that
camera
the 1ab is standing by that's your
camera wait
oh [ __ ] i'm actually so dumb
i'm like i think the smell is getting to
my cutting off oxygen i'm gonna hold it
taut
yeah yeah so there's no flip-flopping
it's just a good hard
lick
here we go
wait my my internet went out
not mine audience is still here watching
okay i want to receive the chat
[Music]
they're all writing family all right
it's just family spam right right now
the cult
ethan clyde is part of a cult
[Applause]
guys come on now
big juicy lick get get a good close-up
of this okay i don't want anyone to miss
don't [ __ ] ever ask me to do this
[ __ ]
again family family family family father
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family
i need the family please keep the family
going family family family family family
family family
family family family family family
family family fam family family family
family family family family
[Applause]
family family family
so salty
[Applause]
cut away
it's gonna puke that away
well i didn't
i didn't breathe through my mouth until
the last minute
it's just
[Music]
well
i think
i think we might have lost ethan
you guys
you guys forced him to do this [ __ ] he's
gone subscribe hit that like button
thank you to all of our beautiful
members
uh we will
are we done ethan
i guess so
all right thanks for watching everyone
we'll see you on friday
[Music]
you